FIRST HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL RESOURCE IN
WATER --
WANT TO WELCOME.
OUR NEW VICE CHAIR BRIAN JONES.
AS WELL AS SOME NEW MEMBERS TO
THE COMMITTEE.
MR BOARD DISMISSED CABALLERO --
THINK MISTER ALLEN --
YOU NEWBIE I JUST DIDN'T
REMEMBER YOU I'M SO SORRY.
IT WAS NOT FORGETTABLE I PROMISE --
BEFORE WE GET STARTED HEARING
MEASURES --
WE NEED TO ADOPT THE COMMITTEE
RULES THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY SESSION --
BUT FIRST WE NEED TO ESTABLISH --
A QUORUM HERE SO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTER STERN HERE STERN
HERE JONES.
JONES HERE ALAN.
ALLEN HERE BURGESS.
BURGESS PRESENT CABALLERO.
CABALLERO HERE HERTZBERG HUESO
JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY HERE VERY GOOD --
SO DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
DISCUSSION FOR MEMBERS ON THE
RULES BEFORE WE TAKE A VOTE ON
ADOPTING THIS NONE WITHOUT ANY
OBJECTION OF THE COMMITTEE RULES
WILL BE ADOPTED --
WE'LL GET STARTED IN FILE OR
WE'RE GOING FILE ORDER TODAY SO
MISTER GLAZER.
DO YOU WANT TO COME PERCENT SB
[inaudible]
EIGHT WELCOME SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS --
WELCOME TO THE NEW YEAR --
AS MANY OF YOU REMEMBER AND I
KNOW YOU HAVE SOME NEW MEMBERS
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
I PRESENTED A SIMILAR BILL --
TO BAN SMOKING IN STATE PARKS
AND BEACHES AND IN PREVIOUS
YEARS.
AS THE ANALYSIS NOTES --
THAT ALTHOUGH THE MEASURE DID
PASS THE LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR
BROWN VETOED IT --
FOR A SECOND TIME AT LEAST AS IT
RELATES TO MY MY WORK IN THIS
AREA -- BUT
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD PROHIBIT
SMOKING AT A UNIT OF THE STATE
PARKS SYSTEM AND MAKE IT
INFRACTION.
PUNISHABLE BY A FINE OF UP TO
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
THE PROHIBITION WOULD ONLY BE
ENFORCED AFTER SIGNS HAD BEEN
POSTED.
THIS BILL AUTHOR AUTHORIZES THE
DIRECTOR OF PARKS AND REC TO
DESIGNATE AREAS IS EXEMPT FROM
THE SMOKING PROHIBITION.
ACCORDING TO THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION TOBACCO KILLS OVER
FORTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
EVERY YEAR.
SECONDS MORE AND COST THE STATE.
MORE THAN TWENTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN HEALTHCARE MEDICARE
OUT.
MEDICAID IN LOST PRODUCTIVITY.
ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS OF
SMOKING AND HEALTH CARE COSTS
THE STATE ARE WELL KNOWN.
A RECENT STATEWIDE POLL
CONDUCTED BY THE LONG
ASSOCIATION.
SO THAT 71% OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT POLICIES THAT PROHIBIT
EXPOSURE TO SECONDHAND SMOKE.
IN AREAS FREQUENTLY REGULATED BY
THE PUBLIC.
BUT SMOKING ALSO HARMS THE
ENVIRONMENT CIGARETTE **** ARE A
MAJOR SOURCE OF WASTE LETTER.
CIGARETTES ALSO BECAUSE WILD
FIRES ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FIRES HAVE
BEEN CAUSED BY SMOKING SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN BANNING
SMOKING IN STATE PARKS IS THE
NEXT STEP IN ADDRESSING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
CONSEQUENCES ASSOCIATED WITH
SMOKING.
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
OUR FEAR AYE VOTE IN SB EIGHT
AND I HAVE WELL TIM GIPSON THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY.
AND RICO MASTER DON ON'T MISTER
BROWSER FOR ME I'M SO BAD.
THE NADA VOSTRO DID NOT OF FROM
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND THANK
YOU [inaudible]
GOOD WELCOME [inaudible]
THE STATE.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TIM GIVES AND I'M WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK AND WE'RE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT SB.
EIGHT SMOKING IS THE LEADING
CAUSE OF PREVENTABLE DEATH IN
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN LUNG CANCER
KILLS OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS EVERY YEAR.
AND OVERALL ONE OUT OF EVERY
THREE DEATHS.
A THREE CANCER DEATHS IS DUE TO
TOBACCO.
THE US SURGEON GENERAL DECLARED
THAT THERE'S NO RISK FREE LEVEL
OF EXPOSURE TO SECONDHAND SMOKE.
EVEN BRIEF EXPOSURE TO
SECONDHAND SMOKE HAS IMMEDIATE
ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS IN ADULTS
AND CHILDREN.
EACH YEAR OVER THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED NONSMOKING ADULTS THE
UNITED STATES WILL DIE OF LUNG
CANCER IS ROLE OF BREEDING.
SECONDHAND SMOKE SECOND SMOKE IS
SPECIALLY HAZARDOUS TO CHILDREN
INDIVIDUALS WITH ASTHMA AND
OTHER CHRONIC ILLNESS ILLNESSES
PREGNANT WOMEN AND THE ELDERLY
SO THE MAJORITY OF OUR
COASTLINES RT SMOKE FREE DUE TO
THE DILIGENT.
WORK OF CITIES AND COUNTIES ONE
GLARING OMISSION IS OUR STATE
BEACHES.
THERE MORE THAN SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION.
PEOPLE UTILIZE THE STATE PARK
SYSTEM EVERY YEAR AND THOSE
GUESTS WHO VISIT THE BEST OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT HAVE THEIR
EXPERIENCE RUINED BY HAVING A
PRE THE HEALTHIER.
SMOKE FREE POLICIES LIKE HIS
ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY IMPROVE
HEALTH AND REDUCE OVERALL
SMOKING.
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
THINK OUR STATE.
PARKS AND BEACHES SHOULD BE
VISUALLY BREATHTAKING NOT
LITERALLY BREATHTAKING SO.
WE REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE
SUPPORT LEGISLATION.
ANSWER.
RITA WELCOME AND THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A WHAT THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND WANT TO
THANK SENATOR GLAZER --
FOR PURSUING THIS --
POLICY I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
AND AS HE AND TEN JUST MENTIONED --
CIGARETTE SMOKE IS WELL
DOCUMENTED AS A NEGATIVE IMPACT
DANGEROUS DEATHLY IMPACT ON
HUMAN HEALTH.
BUT THERE ARE DANGEROUS LONG
AFTER THEY ARE DISCARDED --
THERE'S A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN CIGARETTES OF
BOX.
ON THEY END UP GETTING CONSUMED
BY WILDLIFE --
WHETHER THAT'S BIRDS OR ISH I
WHICH I'VE PERSONALLY SEEN --
THEY DON'T HAVE TO BE CONSUMED
TO BE DANGEROUS THEY LEACH INTO
THE WATER THEY WHICH LEACH INTO
WATER SUPPLY THEY ARE DANGEROUS
TO THE THE WATER QUALITY --
FOR HUMAN 20% OF OUR GARBAGE ON
THE BEACH IS CIGARETTE **** AND
AS MENTIONED THAT BECAUSE WILD
FIRES -- OUR
STATE PARKS ARE PART OF A
NATURAL SYSTEM THAT IS PART OF A
NINETY BILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
OUTDOOR ECONOMY --
WILDFIRES ARE DANGEROUS AND
OBVIOUSLY DEADLY ON FOR AS WE'VE
UNFORTUNATELY SEEN LAST YEAR BUT
THEY ARE AN IMPACT TO OUR
ECONOMY AS WELL SO I RICHER.
I VOTE.
THANK YOU --
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME.
FOR HE MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA
SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA ONE OF THE
LARGEST SOURCES OF POLLUTION
HONOR BEACH IS CIGARETTE BUT WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FORTY MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DUCK HOUSTON REPRESENTED
CALIFORNIA PARK RECREATION
SOCIETY WE ARE TO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
BETSY ARMSTRONG ON BEHALF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS OR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ZACHARY CORE BUT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING THERESA BROKERAGE
ON BEHALF OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION WE SUPPORT
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A HIGHER BASE --
FEATURES TO ENSURE BEHAVIORAL
CHANGE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE MORGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK.
GOOD MORNING WHEN THE RATE IS
FOR THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SO MUCH.
KATHY BURKE WITH THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS PART.
MINUTES AGAIN THOUGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MICHAEL
INTO IMPRISON THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARK RANGERS SOCIAIS XIN.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
RANGERS OF STATION SUPPORTS A
BAN ON SMOKING IN CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS.
WE HAVE ONE CONCERN ABOUT HOW
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
AND THAT IS WE'RE COMING FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF THE RANGER IN THE
FIELD HAVING TO ENFORCE THIS
ENFORCEABILITY.
THE BILL IS CURRENTLY REAL --
WRITTEN ALLOWS --
A EXEMPTION FOR RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS.
RELIGIOUS BELIEF IS A NEBULOUS
ITEM -- IT'D
BE VERY HARD FOR A RANGER IN THE
FIELD TO DETERMINE WHAT A
PERSON'S BELIEF IS WHICH IS
REALLY A SELF EXPRESSION.
WE KNOW THAT RELIGIOUS BELIEFS
HAVE THE FULL GAMUT EVEN THINGS
THAT ARE TOTALLY LEGAL.
MULTIPLE WIVES AND THINGS WITH
THE YOU'LL BE VERY DIFFICULT IN
FACT COULD BECOME IMPOSSIBLE.
TO ENFORCE THIS LAW.
IF SOME. TO FIND A SMOKING AREA
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE NINETY
NINE POINT 9% OF REGULAR SMOKERS.
NOT THOSE WHO ARE PRACTICING A
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
FOUND OUT AND THEY WOULD THROUGH
THE INTERNET AND SOCIAL MEDIA
THAT THE MAGIC WORDS IS
SMOKING'S A PART OF MY RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS.
THE RANGER IN THE FIELD WE HAVE
NO WAY. TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THAT'S TRUE BECAUSE IT'S A
BELIEVE.
IT'S NOT A PRACTICE OR CEREMONY
WHICH IS ALSO IN THE BILL FOR
INSTANCE --
WELL.
SO IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT.
NONE OF THE CURRENT SMOKING BANS
THAT WE RESEARCH HAVE A
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION OF THIS TYPE.
FOR INSTANCE IF THAT EXEMPTION
WAS WRITTEN INTO THE LAW THAT
PROHIBITS SMOKING IN THE
BUILDING AND SOMEONE LIT UP IN
THE AUDIENCE.
AND THE SERGEANT OF ARMS WAS
ASKED. TO HAVE THEM LEAVE WORK
QUIT SMOKING.
AND THEY COULD SAY IT'S MY
RELEASE BELIEVE THE SERGEANT
ARMS WOULD HAVE A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME.
AFTER TRAINING WHAT THAT MEANT.
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT THIS
LANGUAGE WOULD LEAD VERY QUICKLY
TO US SORT OF MAGIC WORD THING
RELIGION IS MY BELIEF --
ALSO PART APARTMENT CURRNTLY
HAS QUITE A FEW LAWS RULES AND
REGULATIONS ON THE CONDUCT
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS.
WE HAVE A WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF
PERMITTING THAT ALLOWS
EXCEPTIONS TO THAT AND THERE'S
THOUSANDS OF THEM.
IT IS EVERYTHING FROM GROUND
FIRES --
LOUD MUSIC RELIGIOUS OR
OTHERWISE AND ALL KINDS OF OTHER
ACTIVITIES.
THESE PERMITS ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT.
TO LOOK AT THE ACTIVITY SAY A
PERSON WANTS TO HAVE AN EVENT
WITH.
LOUD AMPLIFIED MUSIC THEY CAN'T
DO IT ORDINARILY BUT WITH THE
PROPER PERMIT IN THE PROPER
PLACE IN TIME THEY CAN WHETHER
IT'S RELIGIOUS OR OTHERWISE SO.
WE HAVE THE SYSTEM THAT'S IN
PLACE.
WE THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE.
THE WAY TO BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY
WITH THIS IS.
JUST THAT YOU KNOW ONE TENTH OF
A PERCENT.
SO WE'RE PROPOSING AS IT'S
ALREADY IN THE BILL FOR FILMING.
THAT THE LANGUAGE BE AS PROPERLY
PERMITTED [inaudible]
ALTERNATIVELY.
EVEN TAKING OUT THE WORD BELIEF
AND JUST SLOUGHING RELIGIOUS
CEREMONY WE LOVE THE RANGER IN
THE FIELD TO INTERACT WITH THE
PERSON SAY OKAY WHAT'S YOUR
MONEY IS THIS RIGHT IT LOOKS
LIKE YOU JUST SMOKING.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT CEREMONY MAKE
SOME JUDGMENT WHETHER IT'S
LEGITIMATE OR NOT BUT IF THE
PERSON SAYS I JUST BELIEVE IT.
THEIR STOCK.
SO WE ASK THE COMMITTEE. TO
CONSIDER ONE OF THOSE TWO
OPTIONS IN THIS BILL SO THAT IN
THE FIELD WHEN THE RANGERS ARE
OUT THERE TRYING TO ENFORCE IT.
THEY CAN CARRY OUT THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL.
OTHER I GUESS WE'LL REGARD USE A
TWEENER [inaudible]
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THAT'S MAY.
I'M SCOTT SAME PLAYS WE'RE NOT
YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT AS OPPOSED
YOU'RE NOT.
OPPOSED USE AND SMOKING GOT.
GOT IT BUT THIS IS OPPOSITION I
AM NOT OPPOSED TO THE SMOKING
BAN I WROTE THE SMOKING BAN.
WHAT I'M OPPOSED TO IS THIS --
LESS THAN EFFECTIVE LEGISLATION
A CERTAIN SENATOR DECIDED TO DO --
USE RATHER THAN THE GOOD STAFF.
OKAY -- I I
GOT TWO PROBLEMS. TWO MAIN
PROBLEMS HERE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION AGAIN I WROTE THE
LEGISLATION THE ORIGINAL.
STATE PARKS SMOKING BAN
LEGISLATION TO STATE YOUR NAME
IN LIGHTS I DID I'M SCOTT SAME
PLACE.
FROM NO WHERE I'M JUST SOME GUY
THAT WROTE THE LEGISLATION IT
WAS CARRIED ORIGINALLY AND AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN BY MARTY BLOCK.
JUST ENOUGH TO KEEP THIS THIS
HEARING IN ORDER TO START OUT.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
MY TESTIMONY BECAUSE MINE IS AS
VALID AS ANYBODY I WROTE THE
LEGISLATION?
I UNDERSTAND SIR WE'RE JUST
GONNA HAVE TO REFRAIN FROM
CALLING OUT THE THE AUTHOR --
INTENT OKAY OVERALL REFRAIN FROM
THAT I I HAVE TWO PROBLEMS TOO
MANY PROBLEMS WITH THIS THE
FIRST ONE BEING IN THE UP TO
TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR FINE --
FOR VIOLATION THAT'S TOO LOW.
WHEN I WROTE THIS IT WAS UP TO
TWO HUNDRED AND?
IT WAS UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DOLLAR FINE WHICH IS
ONLINE WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LITERAL I FIND.
OKAY -- I'M
NOT WORK IF THERE'S SOME PEOPLE
IT WILL SAY THE UP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IS TO
PUNITIVE.
OKAY I'M TRYING TO DISSUADE
PEOPLE FROM SMOKING IF A
CIGARETTE SMOKER THINKS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HIT WITH A
POTENTIAL FINE OF UP TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS.
THEY'RE MUCH LESS LIKELY TO
SMOKE THAN IF THEY THINK THIS
THAT THE FINE IS A MERE UP TO
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
AND BY MY COMPARED TO OTHER
STATE PARKS SMOKING FINDS THE
OREGON STATE PARKS THEY'RE FINE
IT'S UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS.
NEW JERSEY STATE PARK START AT
TWO IN HAWAII STATE PARKS
SMOKING BAN THE FINE THEY DON'T
EVEN HAVE A SET AMOUNT THERE.
OKAY SO --
THE TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR AMOUNT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET PEOPLE I
DON'T WANT PEOPLE THEY CATCH TO
TO GET HAVE TO PAY.
EXORBITANT AMOUNTS OF MONEY I
JUST DON'T WANT THEM TO SMOKE
THE TWENTY FIVE DAHLE XRAY DRIVE
FIVE DOLLAR FINE IS NOT THE
PROPER SHOW OF FORCE.
THAT'S THAT'S ALMOST ENTRAPMENT
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT OKAY --
THE WHOLE RELIGIOUS BELIEF
EXEMPTION.
I JUST CREATES A MASSIVE
LOOPHOLE TO AT SOME IT'S IT'S
JUST A SEA OF GRAY AREA.
WHAT I SEE IS A RELIGIOUS BELIEF
MIGHT NOT BE WHAT HE CAESAR'S OF
RELIGIOUS BELIEF WHICH MIGHT NOT
BE WHAT SHE SEES AS A RELIGIOUS
BELIEF?
WHO DEFINES THAT ULTIMATELY YOU
REALLY CAN'T IT'S JUST TOO
SUBJECTIVE SO YOU'RE GOING TO
CREATE A MASSIVE BURDEN --
FOR ARE ALREADY OVERWORKED AND
UNDERSTAFFED STATE PARK RANGERS.
AND IF IF YOU CAN'T ENFORCE THIS
THING NOT ONLY IS IT GOING TO BE
A WASTE OF OUR START STATE PARK
RANGERS TIME THIS WILL BE A
WASTE OF MONEY FOR EVERY
TAXPAYER HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR ITS ESTIMATED
SIGNAGE AN INFLAMMATION IS GOING
TO COST SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF A MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S A MILLION DOLLARS
I'M SURE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
COULD BETTER USE ELSEWHERE.
AM I OPPOSED TO THE STATE PARKS
SMOKING BAN ABSOLUTELY NOT AND
MY A CRAP POSTED THIS CURRENT
LANGUAGE YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I WILL RESERVE THAT
FOR THE MEMBERS HERE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE ROBUST TESTIMONY.
WILL WILL --
BRING IT BACK TO THE DICE
MEMBERS DID YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS YES
SENATOR ALLEN.
IS WANTED TO WE HEARD FROM THE
FOLKS WHO REPRESENT THE PEOPLE
ON THE LINE TRYING TO ENFORCE
THESE RULES THAT WE PASS YOUR
FROM SACRAMENTO.
AND I WANTED TO GET A BETTER
SENSE OF THE STATE OF YOUR
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE STATE PARK
RANGERS ASSOCIATION.
AND HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT GO
TO THE TROUBLE OF GETTING THIS I
MEAN THIS IS YOU KNOW A THIRD
ATTEMPT. TO GET ACROSS THE
FOURTH ATTEMPT DOWN TO GET
CROCUS OF STILL.
EVERY WHAT THE TROUBLE AGAIN OF
OF THIS BILL HAD A LOT OF
TROUBLE --
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT IF IT
ACTUALLY IS PASSED ANDSIGNED
INTO LAW?
THE FOLKS WHO ARE AND YOU KNOW.
IT CHARGED WITH WITH WITH
CARRYING IT OUT.
FEEL COMFORTABLE THAT THE GIVES
THEM THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO MEET
THE GOALS THAT.
YOU HAVE.
THE CHAIR YES A THANK YOU THAT
CENTER ALLEN THANKS HERE --
THOUGHTFUL --
INQUIRY I WOULD NOTE A COUPLE
THINGS FIRST DIED IN THE LAST
TWO VERSIONS OF THIS LEGISLATION
THERE WAS NEVER AN ISSUE RAISED
ON THIS POINT AND BY THE WAY.
I WAS GONNA PUT IT MY CLOTHES
BUT KUDOS TO SENATOR MARTY BLOCK
WHO WAS THE ORIGINAL CARRIER OF
THIS BILL --
BEFORE HE LEFT THE THE SENATE
AND I'VE TAKEN THAT ABSENCES
DEPARTURE BUT HE WAS THE ONE WO
IS IT.
ATTEMPTED TO ADVANCE THIS IN
PREVIOUS YEARS I'VE DONE AT THE
LAST TWO SESSIONS --
BUT BUT THESE ISSUES WERE NEVER
REYES BEFORE I I THINK THE
CONCERN IS OVERBLOWN --
BUT NEVER THE LESS THAN HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE PARKS DEPARTMENT
TO FIND AT A WAY --
TO DEAL WITH THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED I THINK THAT
TIED.
AT IO.
WHEN WE HAVE ENACTED SMOKING
BANS IN LOTS OF PLACES IN OUR
STATE OUT RARELY AND WE EVER YOU
KNOW?
HEARD OF ENFORCEMENT ISSUES --
CERTAINLY NOT RELATED TO THE
FINAL THE FIGHT HAS BEEN HIGH
AND IT HAS BEEN LOW AND WE
SUGGESTED THAT TO TRY TO FIND
THE BALANCE AMONG OUR ARE A
THOUGHTFUL LEADERS THAT ARE
MOVING THE BILL FOR THOSE OF THE
RELIGIOUS BELIEF ISSUE.
YEAH SO BUT ON THE RELIGIOUS
BELIEF AND HAPPY. TO TO TO TALK
WITH PART PARKS AND SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO TO TRY TO WORK THAT.
THAT ISSUE OUT --
GOING FORWARD --
DAVE REYES THEY DIDN'T RAISE IN
THE OBJECTION LETTER THAT I SAW.
I WISH I JUST SAW THE YESTERDAY --
THEY DIDN'T AS SUGGEST AS THE
SPEAKER DID AT SOME PERMIT
POLICY IS SOMEWHERE AROUND IT.
NOR DID I HEAR --
THE SUGGESTION ABOUT.
LIMITING THE WORD BELIEVING AND
MAINTAINING THE WORD CEREMONIES
OF THESE ARE NEW THINGS TO ME
AND I'D LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO WORK WITH THEM TO TRY TO
ADVANCE OUR MUTUAL GOALS.
VERY GOOD.
THANKS A CENTER REMINDING THEM
COMMERCENTRE JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN.
WELCOME TO YOUR CHAIRMANSHIP I
THINK THIS IS OUR FIRST HEARING.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS PERSISTENCE I SHARE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL.
OBJECTIVES BUT SURE SOME OF THE
JUST CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS OF
DRAFTING IN CRAFTING IN
ENFORCEMENT.
MAYBE JUST A LITTLE MORE YOUR
THOUGHTS.
ON THE RELIGIOUS.
BELIEF EXEMPTION IN YOUR VIEW
HOW WOULD THAT BE ENFORCED BY A
RANGER IN A PARK WHO COMES
ACROSS SOMEBODY --
LOOKING AT THE SUNSET.
SMOKING A CIGARETTE.
I WILL FIRST AS YOU KNOW PART OF
THE CHALLENGE IS TRYING TO
BALANCE FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
THAT PEOPLE HAVE. TO ENGAGE IN
CERTAIN TYPES OF FIVE OF FIVE
RELIGIOUS ACTIVITIES AND
JUDGMENT CALLS ARE MADE ALL THE
TIME.
IN OUR WORLD.
I IN THE SPACE --
CITATION IS ISSUED IN ITS
CHALLENGE FOR GROUNDS IN WHICH
THEY ARE PROCESS DID YOU TWO
CASES.
BUT I A A I I THINK IT'S VERY
NARROW I THINK IT'S SENSITIVE --
TO TO OUR TRIBES AND OTHER.
FOLKS WHO --%
USED TOBACCO --
IN RELIGIOUS ACTIVITIES I THINK
IT'S THE THE WITH THE EXCEPTION
TO THE RULE --
BUT I ANT TO BE SENSITIVE TO IT
THAT'S WHY IT'S IN THE BILL AS
IT'S BEEN WRITTEN AND HOW ABOUT
CANNABIS USE FROM.
CANNABIS WITH WOULD BE TREATED
THE SAME AS TOBACCO USE --
UNDER THIS BILL.
I MEAN I SHARE THE CONCERN OF
THE STATE PARK RANGER
REPRESENTATIVE.
IF IT'S SIMPLY BASED.
ON AN EXEMPTION FOR RELIGIOUS
BELIEF WITHOUT ANY FURTHER
EXPLANATION.
WORD WILL TRAVEL PRETTY QUICKLY
IF YEAR ACCOSTED BY ARRANGER
JUST SAY YOU SMOKE AS PART OF A
RELIGIOUS BELIEF --
NOW THOSE SMOKING CANNABIS MAY
SAY THEY'RE RASTAFARIANS IN
THERE GONNA HAVE.
THE STRONG ARGUMENT IN COURT
PERHAPS.
BUT I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE GOT AN
ALLY IN THE STATE PARK RANGERS
AND IF THERE'S A WAY TO TIGHTEN.
THE RELIGIOUS BELIEF EXEMPTION --
AS WAS SUGGESTED IT'S PART OF
THE CEREMONY --
OR THERE HAS TO BE SOME FURTHER
ARTICULATION AND JUST SAYING
IT'S MY RELIGIOUS BELIEF.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE HUGE
ENFORCEMENT BURDEN AND WE WON'T
ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVE THE UC IN
THE BILL SO.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT
WITH YOUR COMMITMENT THAT YOU'RE
GONNA CONTINUE.
TO COORDINATE WITH THOSE THAT
ARE GONNA BE ON THE FRONT LINES
OF ENFORCEMENT.
YES CENTER HAPPY HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM AS I
SAID I HEARD THEIR OBJECTION
JUST RECENTLY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM
TO TRY TO SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE
OUT WHETHER IT IF IT'S A
PERMITTING PROCESS IF IT'S A
REPLACEMENT OF THE WORD BELIEF
WITH SOMETHING ELSE THAT --
CREATES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
BILL TO HAPPEN AFFECTS WILL BE
BOTH MUTUALLY.
ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A
QUESTION FOR ONE OF THE
WITNESSES IT MR MASTERED IN
AUTUMN YES DOES IT PROPERLY.
STATE YOU HAD A STATISTIC IN
YOUR IN YOUR TESTIMONY --
REGARDING --
I THINK YOU SAID 20% OF BEACH
LOOKING RESTATE THAT --
STATISTIC FOR ME PLEASE. 20% ONE
IN FIVE THAT CAN WRITE OFF OF
FACTS YOU OF BILL. 20% WHAT. 20%
OF THE BUT GARBAGE THAT PICKED
UP OFF THE BEACH DURING BIG
BEACH CLEANUP IS CIGARETTE ****.
NOW IS SO WHEN YOU SAY
SUPERVISOR 20% OF THE LITTER ON
THE BEACH DO YOU MEAN BY.
WEIGHT BY VOLUME BY ITEM THAT MY
NUMBER OF ITEMS.
BY NUMBER OF ITEMS OKAY I JUST
THAT THAT.
STATISTIC WAS PECULIAR TO ME SO
THANK YOU FOR FOURTH COULD COUNT
CLEAN UP FOR ME.
OKAY VERY GOOD.
WE WE FLOWED INTO OPPOSITION
THERE I JUST WANTED BEFORE WE WE
WRAP UP HERE I DID WANT TO GIVE
OPPORTUNITY IF THERE IS ANY ONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION YOU KNOW IF A
THOROUGH AIRING HERE.
OKAY --
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE DICE --
I'M SPORTING A BILL TODAY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING FORWARD
AGAIN.
FOURTH TIMES THE CHARM PERHAPS --
I DID WANT TO NOTE.
IT'S NOT JUST A RELIGIOUS BELIEF
IT'S THE THE THE THE SECTIONS
SAYS A A GOOD FAITH PRACTICE.
OF A RELIGIOUS BELIEFS SO TERMS
OF THE ROADMAP GOING FORWARD AND
HOW TO NAVIGATE FEASIBILITY
ENFORCEMENT.
A GOOD FAITH PRACTICE MAY BE A
HIGHER THRESHOLD THAN JUST
SIMPLY --
I'M YOUR STATEMENT --
THERE MAY BE OTHER WAYS TO SORT
OF MANAGE THAT WITHOUT IMPEDING
ON FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
POTENTIALLY WHERE YOU HAVE SOME
PRIOR RESTRAINT BUT LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THAT REGARD.
BUT AT HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO SEE THE BILL FORD
AFTER YOU TAKE A MOMENT TO CLOSE.
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU ATTY.
ON SUGGESTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED TO FIND A WAY TO WRITE
THIS BETTER.
I TAKE IT THAT TRIES TO MEET THE
ARE THE BEST PRACTICES IN TERMS
OF ENFORCEMENT BUT IF WE CAN D
THAT BETTER I WOULD ALSO NOTE ON
THE FINE ISSUE THAT.
THERE ARE FINE SAID THAT ARE
ADDED ON TO EVERY FINE SO EVEN A
LEVEL OF TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS TO
FIND COULD BE UP TO TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND IN REALITY I THINK
IT WAS THE OBJECTION THE
GOVERNOR BROWN RAISED ORIGINALLY
ON THE BILL TWO YEARS AGO --
WAS THAT THE FINE COULD I REACH
OVER FOR ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS SO.
IT WAS TRYING TO BE SENSITIVE TO
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW ABOUT
THAT AMOUNT AND LISTEN A LOT OF
TIMES WE WE TRY TO PUT A BASS
LINE --
PROPOSAL IN PLACE IN LAW AND IT
JUST FROM THAT AS WE SEE WHAT'S
WORKING WHAT'S NOT I CERTAINLY
HAVE A COMMITMENT TO YOU IN.
MY OLLEAGUES TO DO IT JUST THIS
IS A GOES FORWARD IT MAKE SURE
IT CAN BE AS EFFECTIVE AS IT CAN
BE AN FAIR.
FAIR TO THOSE.
GOOD THANK YOU --
SENATOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
SO MOVE FROM SENATOR MINING --
PLEASE CALL THE THE ROLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR STERN HI
STERN I'D JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES.
CABALLERO CARILLO I HERTZBERG
HUESO.
JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY BY.
THE BULLS OKAY SIR BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES WE WILL LEAVE IT ON THE
CALL --
THANK CENTER.
SENATOR DODD THE REST THIS
HEARING IS YOUR SIR.
WELCOME.
OKAY THANK YOU --
DO YOU WANT TO START LET'S SEE.
WHAT WE GO?
BUT WE GO FILE ORDER HERE SO IF
YOU DON'T MIND YOU TO PRESENT SB
NINETEEN FIRST TASK [inaudible]
THE RIGHT.
THE J. IT IS THE ALL RIGHT
MISTER HAIRMAN --
IN MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WE'RE HEARING THIS MORNING I'M
PRESENTING SB NINETEEN FOURTEEN
PERTAINING TO STREAM GAGES.
SB NINETEEN WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
DEVELOP A PLAN TO DEPLOY A
NETWORK OF STREAM GAUGES.
INCLUDING A DETERMINATION OF
FUNDING NEEDS IN OPPORTUNITIES
FOR REACTIVATING EXISTING GAUGES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE'RE IN
THE FIFTH YEAR OF DROUGHT
MANAGING OUR WATER SUPPLY WITH
GROWING MORE CRITICAL AND
DIFFICULT.
JUDY GAPS IN THE STATE AND
REGIONAL WATER DATA.
UNDER THE FEAR YOU CAN'T MANAGE
WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW WHY AUTHORED.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY FIVE THE OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT WATER DATA ACT.
PURSUANT TO THE ACT D. W. ARE
THE WATER BOARD AND MANY OTHERS
ARE MAKING TREMENDOUS PROGRESS
ON BUILDING A FEDERATED.
DATA PLATFORM THAT BRINGS
TOGETHER A BROAD RANGE OF
RELATED DATA SETS THAT WATER
MANAGERS AKADEMI ENDS IN
ADMINISTRATORS CAN USE TO MAKE
SCIENCE BASED WATER POLICY
DECISIONS.
NOW THAT THE DATA PLATFORM IS
UNDER CONSTRUCTION IN POPULATED
WITH DATA.
CONTENT --
WOULD WATER QUALITY
CONTEMPORARIES --
WATER DATA.
IT HAS COME TO MY ATTENTION THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS LOST THE ABILITY
TO MEASURE STREAM FLOW A VERY
IMPORTANT TYPE OF DATA. 86% OF
THE STATE'S SIGNIFICANT STREAMS
ARE POORLY GAUGED CALIFORNIA
USED TO HAVE MORE THAN THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED STREAM GAGES MOSTLY
MANAGED BY THE U. S. GEOLOGICAL
SERVICE.
DELIGHTED SERVICE FEES MAY
UNFORTUNATELY THE LAST DECADE
NEARLY HALF OF THOSE GAUGES HAVE
BECOME INACTIVE.
EVEN FEWER GAUGES PROVIDE RICH
REAL TIME REPORTING WITH
FLUCTUATING WEATHER CYCLES ARE
RELIABLE SUPPLY OF WATER IS
DIMINISHED.
IN MANAGING OUR WATER RESOURCES
GROWS MORE IMPORTANT RESTORING
STREAM GAGES AN ESSENTIAL
COMPONENT OF STATEWIDE AND
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY.
SB NINETEEN IS A FIRST UP TO
THAT RESTORATION BY CALLING FOR
A PLAN FOR PRIORITIZATION ENGAGE
LOCATIONS AND FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW HOW.
GAUGE DEPLOYMENT CAN BE FUNDED
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION AS BEING
NINETEEN AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WITH ME TODAY ARE WITNESSES
FROM THE NATURE.
CONSERVANCY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THAT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY I AM --
JAY ZIEGLER WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY --
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB --
NINETEEN WHILE THEY DON'T SOUND
PARTICULARLY SEXY STREAM GAUGES
ARE THE BACKBONE OF WATER REAL
TIME WATERED DATA INFORMATION
NECESSARY. TO EFFECTIVELY MANAGE
RIVERS AND STREAMS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AS SENATOR DODD NOTED --
86% OF CALIFORNIA STREAMS AND
RIVERS --
ARE INADEQUATELY GAUGED AROUND
THE STATE.
SB NINETEEN WILL CALL FOR A PLAN
BETWEEN THE U. S. GEOLOGICAL
SURVEY AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES TO PRIORITIZE
GAUGE REDEPLOYMENT. TO WORK WITH
LOCAL AGENCIES AND OTHER
PARTNERS IN INTEGRATING STREAM
FLOW INFORMATION --
WITH TELEMETRY DATA AND OTHER
SOURCES OF WATER INFORMATION TO
GIVE US A BETTER HANDLE ON HOW
TO MANAGE --
WATER IN OUR STREAMS AND WE
APPLAUD SENATOR DODD'S EFFORTS --
AND BRING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD AND ASK FOR YOUR
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU SIR.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MARK FENSTER MAKER FOR THE
CINEMA COUNTY WATER AGENCY.
AWESOME WATER IS ONE OF THE
LUCKY IN THE STATE TO ACTUALLY
BENEFIT FROM SOME REAL TIME
STREAM GAUGE DATA AND WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT IS THAT REAL
TIME ASPECT --
I SHOULD SAY THAT.
WE ENJOY THIS DATA BECAUSE WE
CONTINUE TO PUT SOME FUNDING
INTO THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
GAUGES IN OUR STREAMS.
I IS THAT LOCAL STATE FEDERAL
PARTNERSHIP WERE REALLY SEEKING
THAT THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN
MORE THAT THE LOCALS PROVIDE
SOME OF THAT.
SHOP MAINTENANCE FUNDING BUT WE
NEED THE STATE TO TO PLAY ITS
ROLE WORKING WITH THE FEDS TO
FULLY DEVELOP A A MORE ROBUST
SYSTEM. FOR US OUT IN THAT SOME
WATER.
WHAT WE BENEFIT FROM THROUGH
THIS DATA IS IS BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF FLOWS HELPS US
IN OUR AT OUR?
MINIMUMS FOR COMPLIANCE WITH
FISH HABITAT.
MY WATER SUPPLY WE USE A VERY
STAYING WE RECENTLY LAUNCHED --
WEBSITE SO THE PUBLIC CAN SEE
THIS DATA --
AS IT MOVES THROUGH OUR OUR
SYSTEM SO WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT
THANK CENTER DOT FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
PER SHARE ABOUT.
THANK YOU --
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
NAME AND AFFILIATION
[inaudible]
FINE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FROST.
I LIVE IN SAN CARLOS CALIFORNIA
ON THE BORDER RESTORE THE DELTA.
AND RESTORE THE DELTA SUPPORTS
THIS LEGISLATION VERY GOOD THANK
YOU.
I KNOW BLESSED HIDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
SANDERSON ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT THANKS
SIR.
GOOD MORNING ROSIE THOMPSON
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING DE ON INSTITUTE A
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
GROUNDWATER COALITION AND THE
GROUND WATER RESOURCES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MORNING THERESA BURKE VERGE ON
BEHALF OF CERES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO BOARD BROOM FOR SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DOWN FOR A COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES A CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANKS MUCH.
RYAN --
JACKING WITH THE REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT THANKS SIR.
BRENNAN DAWSON --
YOU HAVE IS YOUR CALL
CALIFORNIANS [inaudible]
YOU'LL.
MR MEMBERS BATMAN WITH THEIR AND
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT GOOD THANKS SIR.
ROBIN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE.
ANY OPPOSED.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
YES CENTER MONEY.
THANKS FOR BRINGING US BACK I
KNOW IT.
IN MAKE IT THROUGH.
ON THE OTHER SIDE LAST YEAR.
CAN YOU REMIND ME WHY GAUGES
BUILD G. A..
I DID YOU KNOW --
MY CRACK STAFF DID NOT --
I COULD PUT A NOTE ON MY IT OUT
YOU KNOW I'M AT THAT AGE BILL IT
CAN YOU KNOW.
IT'S EXCUSE ME SENATOR.
BURGER MAYBE YOUR STAFF COULDN'T
GET IS THE ANSWER LATER.
NO IT'S NOT RIGHT.
THERE'S A REASON IS THE OLD
ENGLISH SPELLING OF THE FACT
THAT THE RATE IS THE SECTION
SPELLING OF AN EMPHATIC --
GAUGE ADVOCATE AT THE US
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY IN THE EARLY
TWENTIETH CENTURY.
GREEN APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION AND THANK YOU FOR
THE HISTORICAL REMINDER --
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS YES
AND AROUND.
WELL I WAS GONNA ASK YOU LAST
YEAR ABOUT THIS.
AND IT WITH THE I CAN REMEMBER
THAT YEAH YEAH.
IT IS TO BE WAS A BIT WAS
BASICALLY A AT AN ENGINEER ABOUT
A HUNDRED YEARS AGO DECIDED TO
KIND OF SWITCH IT FROM THE
ENGLISH SPELLING. TO GET BACK TO
THE AGENTS ACCIDENTS SO --
SO HERE WE ARE.
IT'S ALL VERY EXCITING.
THAT'S IT THAT'S WHAT YOU GOT.
WHICH IS.
MAY KIDDING TIME WE CAN BE.
DIG IN LET'S DIGGING DEEPER.
WHAT IS A SAXON ANYWAYS YOU KNOW?
I I DID HAVE ONE SERIOUS
QUESTION OF FOR MISTER MAY MR
ZIEGLER IS PROFESSOR MAKER IN
TERMS OF OUR ABILITIES STATE TO
UPGRADE THE THE OLDER GAUGES OUT
THERE I SEE SOME OF THE DATA IT
SAYS.
ABOUT THIRTY SIX HUNDRED
LOCATIONS ONLY 54% ACTIVE
RECENTLY.
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT A WHOLE NEW
SYSTEM TO ACTUALLY GET THAT KIND
A REAL TIME DATA BACK THAT WE
NEED OR IS THERE.
ARE THERE TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE
TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO GO IN AND
RETROFIT AND MAYBE GO BACK TO
SOME OF THESE.
SORT OF SAU LOADER YOU KNOW MR
SHATTERED LOCATIONS IN A AND
REINVIGORATE THEM WITHOUT A
WHOLE OVER ALL.
RIGHT WHAT THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION I I THINK OUR ESTIMATE
IS THAT A GOOD NUMBER OF THE
GAUGES THAT ARE IN ACTIVE TODAY --
YOU KNOW FOR PERHAPS A THIRD OF
THE GAUGES COULD BE REACTIVATED --
WITH VERY MINIMAL EFFORT AT THE
CHECK CLIMATE OF AN INDIVIDUAL
GAUGE WHICH PROVIDES --
STREAM FLOW WATER QUALITY WATER
TEMPERATURE INFORMATION --
EACH AN INDIVIDUAL GAUGES ABOUT --
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND AND TO
ABOUT HALF THAT USGS ESTIMATES
FOR AN AVERAGE GAUGE TWELVE
THOUSAND A YEAR AND MAINTENANCE
COSTS --
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN TALKING WITH --
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES ABOUT
IS A FORMULA IN WHICH THE THE
STATE MAY USE PROP ONE OR OTHER
BOND FUNDS. TO DEPLOY THE GAUGES
TO DEVISE OF THAT COST AND TO
HAVE A PARTNER SHARING AGREEMENT
WITH HE LOCAL AGENCIES AND U.
S. G. S. PICKING UP MORE OF THE
MAINTENANCE COST OF THOSE GAUGES
AND SO.
WE THINK THERE'S A PATH FORWARD
HERE -- THAT
REALLY JUST REQUIRES THE
AGENCIES TO GET TOGETHER IN AN
INTEGRATED PLAN VERY GOOD.
BUT I'D I'D APPRECIATE THE
FOLLOW UP ON YOUR LEGISLATION
LAST YEAR CENTER DIED IN TRYING
TO SORT OF ADD.
THIS DATA SAID IN IS CRITICAL
FOR ACTUALLY GONNA.
SAVE OUR ENVIRONMENT AND AND
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT FLOWS
WE'RE DEALING WITH HERE TO
ACTUALLY COME UP WITH IN THE
TIDWATER PLAN FOR CALIFORNIA
THAT WORK SO --
WITH THAT ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE AN
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
THANK YOU.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ANYONE'S GOT.
ONE THANK YOU CENTER MONEY.
THE MOTIONS TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR STERN HI
STERN I'D JONES ALAN.
ALLEN AYE BRIDGES CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY
[inaudible]
MONNING I THAT HAS FAILED --
WEIRD FIVE VOTES BUT WE WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL.
VERY GOOD NEXT SENATOR DIED --
SB.
SIXTY TWO YES MR MEMBERS SB
SIXTY TWO ADDRESSES TWO SUNSETS
IN LAWS PERTAINING TO ENDANGERED
SPECIES.
SB SIXTY TWO ELIMINATES A SUNSET
CONCERNING PROTECTIONS AGAINST
ACCIDENTAL TAKE --
OF ENDANGERED SPECIES.
AXLE TAKE PROVISIONS WERE
ORIGINALLY ENACTED INTO LAW IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN REDUCE IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO RENEWED IN
200-082-00010 IN. TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN TO OUR KNOWLEDGE THERE
HAVE NOT BEEN COMPLAINTS.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SPEND THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS EVERY TWO OR THREE YEARS
TO KEEP EXTENDING THIS LAW.
THE BILL DOES ADD HOWEVER FOR
THE FIRST TIME A REQUIREMENT
THAT THE FARMER WHO ACCIDENTALLY
TAKES A SPECIES REPORT THE EVENT
TO FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THE REPORTING IS AN IMPORTANT
IMPROVEMENT SO WE KNOW HOW OFTEN
THESE ACCIDENTAL TAKES OCCUR.
THE AMENDMENT I'VE ACCEPTED
WOULD REQUIRE DFW TO INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE NUMBER IN
NATURE OF ACCIDENTAL TAKE
REPORTS.
SECOND THE BILL ALSO EXTEND THE
SUNSET OF THE SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENT --
PROGRAM ACT UNTIL.
JANUARY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FOUR THE CALIFORNIA SAFE
HARBOR AGREEMENT PROGRAM ACTING
COURAGE'S LANDOWNERS TO MANAGE
THEIR LANDS TO AGREEMENT WITH
DFW.
IN A MANNER THAT PROTECTS
THREATEN ENDANGERED SPECIES THAT
ACT IS SET TO EXPIRE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY DFW HAS
APPROVED EIGHT SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENTS SINCE THE PROGRAM WAS
ENACTED.
SB SIXTY TWO WOULD EXTEND THE
ACT FOR ANOTHER FOUR YEARS.
TO TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR
TAKEN TOGETHER THE TWO LAWS
AFFORD PROTECTIONS FOR BOTH
FARMERS AN ENDANGERED SPECIES
WHICH ALLOWS WORKING LANCE TO
CONTINUE A PRODUCTION BUT ALSO
ENCOURAGE MANAGEMENT.
OF THOSE WORKING LANCE TO
BENEFIT WILDLIFE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND AN
AYE VOTE --
NO WELL --
CREAMERS FROM THE DAY TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD.
BILLS IN SUPPORT WELCOME I KNOW
WELL KRAMER'S OF CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS AND I WHAT DOES THAT
MAYBE WE CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF ADDING
A SUNSET IN.
FOR THAT AXONAL TAKE PROVISION
IN EXCHANGE FOR REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE TO REPORT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE ME TO THE
PUNCH A WONDERFUL OKAY --
WELL.
I JUST WANTED TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT -- THE
AXONAL TAKE PROVISION IN THE
CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT IS A VALUABLE PIECE.
OF PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
FARMERS AND RANCHERS THAT
REMOVES ANY DISINCENTIVE FROM
PROVIDING WILDLIFE HABITAT ON
THEIR FARMS AND RANCHES BY
GIVING THEM PROTECTION IF THEY
ACCIDENTALLY TAKE A LISTED
SPECIES IN AXONAL TAKE IS
DIFFERENT THAN INCIDENTAL TAKE --
IT TRULY HAS TO BE AN ACCIDENT
OR HAS TO BE UNINTENDED OR
UNFORESEEN.
A AND AND THOSE ARE VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT WE IT'S A VERY
BUT STILL IS A VALUABLE PIECE OF
LAW THAT HELPS --
FARMERS AND RANCHERS CONTINUE
BEING SUCCESSFUL IN CALIFORNIA
AND THE SAFE HARBOR PROVISIONIS
ALSO IMPORTANT INVALUABLE IN
HELPING --
FOLKS.
VIED HABITAT --
FOR AN INCREASE HABITAT FOR
LISTED SPECIES AND AND WE
SUPPORT EXTENDING THE SUNSET --
FOR THAT AND I'M HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF ANYONE HAS A
VERY.
FAMOUS CARS.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT GETTING OUR LETTER IN ON
TIME -- BUT
OUR MEMBERS PARTICULARLY FIND
THE CALIFORNIA'S --
STATE SAFE HARBOR AGREEMENT
PROGRAM --
IMPORTANT FOR OUR MEMBERS UNDER
THE PROGRAM OUR MEMBERS
VOLUNTARILY WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND MANAGE OUR ANDS IN A WAY
THAT ENHANCE THE HABITAT FOR THE
POPULATION.
OF LISTED SPECIES IN A RETURN
THAT APART TO ALLOW FOR THE
INCIDENTAL TAKE A PROTECTED
SPECIES BUT ONLY IF THERE'S AN
AT CONSERVATION BENEFIT FOR THE
COVERED SPECIES.
WE APPRECIATE CENTER DOT
INTRODUCING THIS BILL THANKS SO
MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI I'M GAIL DEL HAT WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
HERE IN SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK
YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER HAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE JACK I'M HALF OF
AMERICANS DASHIELL GROWERS
AFRICAN AMERICAN FARMERS
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL.
CALIFORNIA DAIRIES IN CALIFORNIA
RICE CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRIES%
CALIFORNIA TOMATO GROWERS
WESTERN PLAN HEALTH AND FAR WEST
EQUIPMENT DEALERS IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD THANK.
THE CELL BE ON A BEHALF OF A
CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED THE ALLMAN
ALLIANCE AND A FEW OTHER
AGRICULTURAL ENTITIES AND
SUPPORT FOR YOU THANKS SIR.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANKS SO MUCH.
YES -- WE
WILL ALLOW FOR TWEETERS NOW
[inaudible] ONE A MISTER CHAIR
JENNIFER FEARING ON BEHALF OF
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND I'M
NOT SURE QUITE WHERE THE
COMMITTEE MIGHT BE HEADED AND SO
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE TESTIMONY
I'M GIVING WILL BE.
AMELIORATED --
AT LEAST --
SIGNIFICANTLY BUT DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE WAS THE ORIGINAL
SPONSOR OF THE SENATOR PAVLEY
BILL -- THAT
THIS BILLS EXTENDING --
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
VERY MUCH BECAUSE IT REPORTING
REQUIREMENT FOR ANYONE WHO USES
THE ACCIDENTAL TAKE PROVISION
AND WOULD EXTEND THE LIFE OF THE
SAFE HARBOR PROGRAM AND WE DO
WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
TO TAKE. TO TAKE THE AND OR THE
AUTHOR I'M SORRY TO TAKE THIS
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
OFFERED BY THE COMMITTEE.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
SUNSET PROVISION OF THE-ACCIDENTAL TAKE PROVISION
REINSTATED SO AT SUNSET AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE SPONSORS INTERESTED IN
THAT AS WELL AS LONG AS THAT IS
PAIRED.
WITH A REPORT --
INTO DFW BY FARMERS AND WE WOULD
BE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
AMENDMENT TO THE BILL.
AND I THINK THE LAST PIECE THAT
HASN'T BEEN DISCUSSED THAT IS AN
ADDRESSED WOOD WE THINK THAT
IT'S TIME TO ELIMINATE THE
SUNSET ALL TOGETHER FOR THE SAFE
HARBOR PROGRAM --
BUT WE'D LIKE AS I MENTIONED WE
ORIGINALLY SPONSORED THAT
LEGISLATION STRONGLY BELIEVE IN
THE NEED TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES
FOR LANDOWNERS TO PROACTIVELY
RESTORING CONSERVE LANDS.
BAD THAT EIGHT SAFE HARBOR
AGREEMENTS HAVE THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED OF OCCURRED IN SIX
COUNTIES AND IT PROTECT SIX
IMPERILED SPECIES.
THE PROGRAM IS A SUCCESS AND THE
TIME IS COME TO REMOVE THE
SUNSET PROVISION ENTIRELY TO
PERMANENTLY ENSURE THE
AVAILABILITY OF THE PROGRAM TO
LANDOWNERS SO.
WITH THAT SAID OF CHANGES TO THE
BILL WE WOULD BE PLEASED TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
FOR THAT TWEENER TESTIMONIES ANY
OPPOSITION OUT RIGHT.
SEE NINE MEMBER DO YOU ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
BEFORE I ENTERTAIN THAT MOTION I
WANTED.
TO HAVE A BRIEF EXCHANGE BUT
CENTER COMING UP PLEASE.
NOT CLEAR TO ME WHETHER THE
AMENDMENTS ARE BEING TAKEN IN
AND FRANKLY I WAS TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW.
THE THE SENTENCE ON AMENDMENT
NUMBER ONE OPERATES.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT IT'S
NARROWING IT.
TO FARMERS RANCHERS AND
EMPLOYEES AS OPPOSED TO THE
BROADER.
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED ABOUT.
IRRIGATION DISTRICTS AND OTHER
YES.
SO.
SO I'M I'M I'M GOOD WITH THAT
AND I'M I'M ASSUMING THAT --
DOCTORS GOING TO TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL I THINK IT'S IT'S WELL
DONE I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT WERE SUNSET.
THAT THAT WAS A LITTLE CONFUSING
TO ME.
SO SO WHY DON'T --
WHAT I JUMP IN HERE THEN?
THE SON SAID THAT'S BEING
DISCUSSED IS UP WAS POSED BY THE
SPONSORS ARE THE ARE THE
SUPPORTERS AS POTENTIAL
SUBSTITUTION FOR THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT --
TO CDF W. FOR THIS SAFE FOR WHO
USES THE SAFE HARBORS AMONG THE
FARMERS SO.
IN OTHER WORDS THE THE THE COSTS
ARE ADMINISTRATIVELY THAT WOULD
BE --
UNDERTAKEN BY CITY OF W. INTAKE
THE AYE AYE WE WE HAVE TO FIGHT
AFTER THE AUTHOR WHAT HE'S OPEN
TO BUT IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
FINDING A WAY TO HAVE SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THIS PROGRAM
UNDERSTAND IT FUNCTIONS.
THE IDEA IS THAT THE SUNSET
WHICH TO SERVE A SIMILAR
FUNCTION TO THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD SATISFY --
THE TWENTY YEARS BUT I DID WANT
TO GET YOUR TAKE I KNOW WE'VE
TALKED TO STAFF AND SOME OF YOUR
SPONSORED ABOUT IT BUT ARE YOU
WOULD YOU BE AMENABLE. TO
SUBSTITUTING SAY THAT OF A FOUR
YEAR SUNSET --
LIKE WE WOULD LIKE WE DISCUSSED
HERE -- FOR
THAT REPORTING REQUIREMENT.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY --
I I DO I DO RECOGNIZE THE I
DEFENDERS WILDLIFE'S CONCERNED
ABOUT --
HAVING SOME ONGOING.
REPORTING GOING FOR TO SORT OF
KNOW HOW THIS IS FUNCTIONING SO --
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THAT
COMPLETELY OFF THE TABLE VOTE
FOR PURPOSES OF NOT.
THE TRYING TO COMPLETELY AMEND
THE BILL FROM THE DICE HERE
TODAY I THINK THE IDEA WOULD BE
TO HAVE THE AUTHOR TAKEN AUTHORS
AMENDMENT --
FOR THIS FOR YOUR SON SAID
REPORTING REQUIREMENT AND THEN I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU JUST TO KEEP
WORKING WITH THE TWENTY YEARS
OUT THERE.
TO SEE IF WE CAN FIND SOME WAY
TO FIND ACCOUNTABILITY ON THAT
THAT PIECE SO DOES THAT HELP
CLARIFY THINGS OKAY VERY GOOD --
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION FROM CENTER
HUESO DID YOU WANNA CLOSE.
LIKE LAST YEAR I HAVE A VERY
GOOD -- THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATE STERN HI FERN I'D JONES
ALLEN.
ALLEN I BARGES CABALLERO
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY I JUST FIVE BELIEVING
CHOQUET SO THAT WE HAVE FIVE
VOTES THERE WE WILL LEAVE THAT
ON CALL --
AND YOUR FINAL MEASURE THE DAY
AS BE -- TO
FOR YES MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SB TWO OH
FOUR REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES.
D. W. R. AND THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. TO INFORM LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES OF PENDING STATE
WATER PROJECT CONTRACTS IN
AMENDMENTS.
WE ALL KNOW THE CALIFORNIA WATER
FIXES A PROPOSAL TO BUILD A
CONVEYANCE UNDER THE DELTA TO
DIRECTLY SHIP WATER TO STATE
WATER PROJECT'S.
PUMPS.
THE TUNNELS OF CONSTRUCTED WILL
BE PART OF THIS.
DEVELOPMENT OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE OF THE PROJECT IS
CARRIED OUT BY D. W. R. PURSUANT
TO CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE D. W.
R..
IN STATE WATER CONTRACTORS THE
CONTRACTS COVER MATTERS SUCH AS
THE AMOUNT OF DELIVERABLE WATER
ALLOCATION ACOSTA BUILDING IN
SUPPLY ISSUES THAT ARE UNIQUE TO
EACH CONTRACTOR.
ADDITIONALLY THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY.
HAS BEEN CREATED A PLAN DESIGNED
TO CONSTRUCT THE WATER FIX
PROJECT.
UNDER THE OVERSIGHT OF D. W. R..
TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE KNOW
VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE WATER FIX
CONTRACTS.
BEYOND THE FACTS THAT JUST
STATED.
WE READ A LOT OF NEWS ARTICLES
AND TALK TO A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT
THERE IS LITTLE IN THE WAY OF
REQUIRED INFORMATION D. W. R.
HAS TO SUBMIT. TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE FACT IS FUNDING FOR WATER
FIX IS CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED
THEREFORE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
THAT IS TYPICALLY.
PERFORMED BY THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE SIMPLY DOESN'T OCCUR.
THE APPLICATIONS IN IMPACTS OF
WATER FIX OUR ENORMOUS. FOR MY
DELTA CONSTITUENTS WATER FIX
THREATENS MASSIVE DISRUPTIONS TO
THE DELTA'S REGIONAL
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY COMMUNITY
CULTURE AND SAFETY AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS. TO
NUMEROUS TO QUOTE. FOR THE REST
OF THE STATE WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT HALF THE WATER RATE
INCREASES AND POTENTIAL
INCREASES THE PROPERTY TAXES
NECESSARY TO FUND THIS PROJECT.
SB TWO OH FOUR SIMPLY PUT IS
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY INSURING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS MADE FULLY
AWARE OF PENDING CONTRACTUAL
OBLIGATIONS D. W. R. IN THE GPA
WHICH TO ENTER INTO.
BEFORE THEY HAPPEN WITH
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE FEEDBACK AND
INPUT THROUGH HEARINGS OR
WRITTEN COMMENTARY.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SUGGEST
AMENDMENTS TO TIGHTEN UP THE
PERIOD OF TIME BETWEEN
SUBMISSION OF REQUIRED
INFORMATION AND REVIEW BY THE
JAIL BC AND RELEVANT COMMITTEES
AS WELL AS THAT OF FLOOR. FOR
THE MINIMUM OUT OF COD CONTRACTS
SUBJECT TO THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL.
ASSURED THAT THE BILL STILL
ACCOMPLISHES MY THE IN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT --
THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE --
HERE TO TESTIFY IN THE BILL IS
SACRAMENTO COUNTY SUPERVISOR DON
TO TOTALLY IN FOR ME STORE THE
DELTA BARBARA BERRIGAN PARTY --
GOOD -- GOOD
MORNING --
GERMAN STERN IN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE I AM VERY PLEASED TO
BE HERE WITH YOU TO JOIN SENATOR
DODD.
TO AND OTHERS --
IN SUPPORTING THIS LEGISLATION
BEFORE YOU AS IS THE BEEN --
AMENDED.
I WANT TO KNOW DE DE DA COUNTIES
COLLECTION REPRESENTS THE FIVE
COUNTIES OF CONTRA COSTA
SACRAMENTO YOU LOS LLANOS AND WE
CAN COUNTY.
AND THAT --
TOGETHER WE WORK --
TO IN CONCERT --
OVER THE COURSE OF MANY AND ON
PROJECTS THAT --
WILL IN A POTENTIALLY HAVE
IMPACT IN THIS CASE HAVE IMPACT
ON THE DELTA IN THIS COMMUNITIES.
WE UNDERSTAND THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION --
PLANS ON REVISIONS --
TO THE OF THE PREVIOUS HE
PROPOSED WATER FIX PROJECT.
AND THAT --
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT DON'T
BECAUSE COLLISION THAT --
IS NECESSARY FOR THE THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT --
WITH THIS NEW DIRECTION --
BEING SUGGESTED.
WE ALSO AGREED IT'S IMPERATIVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED
THIS OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY ON
THE REVISED PROJECT.
RELATED CONTRACTS AS A CENTER
DODD TO SO AB POINTED OUT.
BECAUSE IT'S WATER PROJECT AS IT
CONTINUES APPROPRIATION IS
MENTIONED THAT PART OF WATER
RESOURCES --
IMPROPER PARTICIPANTS HAVE NOT
HAD TO COME BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE TO UPDATE COMMITTEES
ON ACTIVITIES WERE JUSTIFIED THE
EXPENDITURE OF THE PLAN ON THE
PLANS.
THIS IS OF GREAT CONCERN TO
DELTA COUNTIES IN TO THE FOLKS
THAT WE REPRESENT.
BECAUSE THROUGHOUT THE PAST TEN
YEARS.
IMAGE OF CONTINUE TO PRESS
FORWARD ON A A PLAN THAT WE
BELIEVE WILL HAVE A TREMENDOUS
IMPACT ON DELTA COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITIES PEOPLE REPRESENT.
AND SO THEREFORE WE TO
DILIGENTLY JOURNEYS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE WORK IS BEING DONE IS
APPROPRIATE.
REASONABLE CONSISTENT WITH A CO
EQUAL GOALS OF COURSE PROTECTS
AND PRESERVES THE UNIQUE VALUES
OF THE DELTA.
THE DELTA REGION IS CERTAIN TO
EXPERIENCE ENVIRONMENTAL DAMAGE
THE LOSS OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES
OF AGRICULTURAL LANDS.
WITH THIS MASSIVE PROJECT.
AS WELL AS STATED BY SENATOR
DODD DELTA RESIDENTS WILL BE
TREMENDOUSLY IMPACTED THROUGH
THE CONSTRUCTION PERIOD AND FOR
THE EVER AFTER.
THE DELTA COUNTIES ALSO
LEGISLATURE TO OVERSEE THE WATER
FIX PROJECT IN INDIA WRITTEN
INTO YOUR AERATION NEW OR
OTHERWISE.
ENSURE THE PUBLIC KNOWS HELD
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE SPENT
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE SPENT.
AND CONTINUOUSLY EVALUATES OF
THE ONGOING IMPACTS OF THIS
PROJECT.
THE DCC WANT TO THANK SENATOR
DODD MEMBERS OF OUR DOT COUNTY
DELEGATION FOR AUTHORING HIS
BILL AND WE BELIEVE THAT SB TOOL
FOR AS AMENDED WILL BRING.
GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PROCESS FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
OF THOSE AND OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STERN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M BARBARA
BERRA GAME PRE ON ON THE SECOND
OF DIRECTOR FOR RESTORE THE
DELTA.
ON BEHALF OF OUR ORGANIZATION
AND OUR SIXTY THOUSAND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR
FULL SUPPORT FOR SB TWO OH FOUR
AND THE AMENDMENTS.
YOU HAVE IN YOUR FILE OF A
COALITION LETTER.
THAT WE SENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SIGNED BY OVER FORTY GROUPS
RANGING FROM BUSINESS CHAMBERS
TWO TRIBES TO FISHING GROUPS TO
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS. TO
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEY REPRESENT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
IN ADDITION YOU HAVE AN A A
LETTER THAT HAS OVER FIFTEEN
HUNDRED SIGNATURES OF VARIOUS
INDIVIDUALS ALSO IN IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
DESPITE WATER FIX PROPONENTS
HAVING SPENT FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN PLANNING OVER
TWELVE YEARS.
pTHE WATER AVAILABILITY ANALYSIS
A DETAILED PUBLIC AND
TRANSPARENT FINANCIAL PLAN
DOCUMENTING WHO WILL PAY.
AND A COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS THAT
EVALUATES THE ECONOMIC VALUE OF
FRESH WATER TO THE BAY DELTA.
AND COASTAL ECONOMIES.
A THOROUGH UNDERSTANDING BY THE
LEGISLATURE OF THE STATE WATER
CONTRACT EXTENSION FOR WATER FIX.
AND CONTRACTS MADE BY THE TWO
WATER FIXED JOINT POWER
AUTHORITIES.
CAN HELP SHED LIGHT ON SOME OF
THESE.
WATER FIXES DESCRIBED BY D. W.
ARE AT THE STATE WATER BOARD
PERMIT HEARINGS INDICATES THAT
WATER WILL BE EXPORTED THROUGH A
TUNNEL DURING WET PERIODS.
USING ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT TOOLS
IN A VARIABLE RANGE THAT WILL BE
DETERMINED BY WATER EXPORTERS
INDEED W. ARE AT A LATER DATE.
HOWEVER WATER DELIVERY MODELS
CREATED BY METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SHOW THAT MORE WATER WILL BE
TAKEN FROM THE DELTA DURING DRY
PERIODS THAN AT PRESENT.
WHEN DELTA COMMUNITIES DURING
THOSE DRY PERIODS NEED FLOWS TO
FLUSH OUT SALINITY TOXINS IN
ALGAL BLOOMS FROM THE ESTUARY?
TO UNDERSTAND IN GREATER DETAIL
WHAT THE IMPACT WILL BE ON OUR
WATER QUALITY DELTA PUBLIC
INTEREST GROUPS NEED TO BE ABLE
TO LEARN OF AND EVALUATE THE
WATER FIX CONTRACT EXTENSION.
BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE THE REAL
DECISIONS REGARDING WATER
EXPORTS WILL BE SPELLED OUT.
AND PARTICIPATING IN OBSERVING
THE STATE WATER CONTRACT PROCESS.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY ANSWER ALL
THOSE QUESTIONS. FOR INSTANCE
WHEN WE ONE UNDERSTAND
CONTRACTUAL DECISIONS IN
NEGOTIATIONS AS WITH THE
COORDINATED OPERATING AGREEMENT
BETWEEN STATE AND FEDERAL WATER
CONTRACTORS.
AROUND WATER DELIVERIES WERE
FORCED TO SUBMIT PUBLIC RECORD
ACT REQUESTS.
IT TAKES D. W. R. N. M. W. D.
BETWEEN THREE AND SIX MONTHS TO
REPLY TO OUR REQUESTS AND THE
INFORMATION THAT WE RECEIVE IS
SO HEAVILY REDACTED WE CAN NEVER
FULLY GAIN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
THE STATE WATER CONTRACT
EXTENSION FOR WATER FIX IT HAS
TO BE ANALYZED IN COMPARISON TO
OTHER PROCESSES.
SB TWENTY FOUR WILL HELP US MAKE
THOSE COMPARISONS.
ADDITIONALLY WATER FIX HAS JUST --
WATER FIX AS IT'S BEEN DESCRIBED
IN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE STATE
WATER BOARD DOES NOT MATCH IN
DETAIL WITH WATER DELIVERY
PROMISES MADE BY THE MANAGEMENT.
OF METROPOLITAN TO CUSTOMER THE
BOUNDARIES OF ITS MEMBER
AGENCIES.
MY STAFF AND I HAVE ATTENDED
DOZENS OF MEETINGS THROUGHOUT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WERE
PROMISES WERE MADE TO WATER.
OUR CUSTOMERS WATER RATE PAYERS
THE THIRD DISTRICT OR
MUNICIPALITY WOULD NOT HAVE TO
PAY FOR WATER THEY DID NOT
RECEIVE.
YET ANNUAL BOND REPAYMENTS WILL
REMAIN CONSTANT.
AND A LARGE AMOUNT OF DEBT
CARRIED BY MATT WILL REQUIRE
MAJORITY IF NOT 100% MEMBER
AGENCY PARTICIPATION FOR THAT
REPAYMENT.
WELL THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN PROMISED BY TOTAL
PROPONENTS THAT THOSE RECEIVING
THE WATER WOULD PAY FOR THE
PROJECT.
WE KNOW THAT IN ADDITION TO
VOLUMETRIC SALES OF WATER MATT
WILL SPREAD DEBT REPAYMENT FOR
WATER FIX ACROSS WATER
TRANSPORTATION CHARGES AND VERY
LIKELY THROUGH PARCEL TAXES.
IN OTHER WORDS CUSTOMERS WHO
WILL NOT RECEIVE WATER FROM THE
PROJECT WILL HELP TO REPAY ITS
BOND DEBT. FOR TWO TO FOUR
GENERATIONS.
THIS IS WHY THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS THE TIME SB TWO OH FOUR
PROVIDES FOR EVALUATION OF THE
WATER FIX CONTRACT EXTENSION.
THIS IS WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
CAN ASK HOW BOND REPAYMENTS
WHICH WILL REMAIN CONSTANT EVERY
YEAR.
EVEN DURING YEARS OF EXTENDED
DROUGHT ONE LITTLE WATER WILL BE
DELIVERED WILL BE REPAID FOR
WATER FIX GPA MEMBERS.
DESPITE GOVERNOR NEWSOME HITTING
THE RESET BUTTON FOR WATER FIX
THE DESIGN CONSTRUCTION FINANCE
AUTHORITY.
HAS CONTINUED MOVING AHEAD WITH
HIRING CONTRACTORS WHILE THE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION GPA HAS
HIRED A FIRM FROM GERMANY TO
BEGIN FULL DESIGN OF THE PROJECT.
WHERE IS THE MONEY COMING FROM
TO FINANCE THESE ACTIVITIES?
HOW MUCH OF THE GPAS ACTIVITIES
ARE BEING FINANCED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES?
THE PUBLIC HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW
THE ANSWER.
THE EXECUTION OF SB TOOL FOR
WOULD SET IN PLACE IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN.
D. W. OURS PROPOSED CONTRACT
AMENDMENTS IN THE ACTIVITIES OF
THE DSC AND THE CONSTRUCTION
AUTHORITIES WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL PASS SB TWO OH FOUR WITH
ITS AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I KNOW YOU IT
SLIGHTLY TWEAKED RAGWORT AND
SEEKING AMENDMENTS COULD YOU
TELL ME JUST READ RUN THROUGH
SUPPORT REAL QUICK AND THEN
WE'LL.
COME RIGHT THROUGH SO WE JUST
RUN THROUGH SUPPORTERS
ADDITIONAL JUST PURE SUPPORT.
PARDON ME YES.
THANK YOU HELLO GOOD MORNING
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS MICHAEL
FROST.
I'M FROM SAN CARLOS CALIFORNIA
ON THE BORDER RESTORE THE DELTA.
IN A WANTED TO MAKE A COUPLE
POINTS TO BEGIN WITH YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA WATER IS OF YOU JUST
WE DO WE GAVE TWO MINUTES --
TO TO THIS SUPPORTERS SO YOU
WANT TO JUST KEEP CAN YOU GIVE
ME THIRTY SECONDS HERE YEAH OKAY.
WATER IS A PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCE
THIS IS CRITICAL TO OUR TO OUR
DEMOCRACY CALIFORNIA WATER RATE
PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS NEED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THIS PROCESS.
TRANSPARENCY IS CRITICAL.
AND THE J. P. A. D. W. OUR WATER
CUT CONTRACTORS NEED TO BE HELD
TO ACCOUNT.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO OF
FOUR THANK YOU SIR APPRECIATE IT
AS MUCH.
GOOD MORNING A DâN RIGHT VICE
MAYOR AND COUNCIL MEMBER
REPRESENTING THE THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS OF THE
CITY OF STOCKTON --
AS CONSUMERS OF DELTA WATER WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL WHICH
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY AND ALLOW
US ANOTHER REPAIRS HAVE.
AN AVENUE TO EXPRESS CONCERNS
AND OR SEEK MITIGATION. FOR ANY
REAL AND POTENTIAL FIX THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OTHERS.
BRENNAN DAWSON NUMBER HAVE A
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
OCEAN RESERVE FROM LOCAL
AGENCIES OF THE NORTH DELTA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOMETHING EVEN
STRONGER BUT IF THIS IS THE BILL
THAT CAN GO THROUGH WE CERTAINLY
SUPPORT MORE TRANSPARENCY. FOR
THIS PROJECT WHICH HAS BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT AS MS BERRIGAN PRIA.
NOTED TO FIND.
ANSWERS ABOUT THE MOST BASIC
QUESTIONS WITH FINANCING SO WE
WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANCE IN THIS
REGARD THANKS THANK YOU.
SEEING NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT WILL
NOW GO TO SUPPORT PLUS SEEKING
AMENDMENTS CORRECT --
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
STEVE CREWS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY THAT APOLOGIZE WE DID
SUBMIT.
A LETTER --
JUST YESTERDAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SO AGAIN APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TARDINESS OF THE LETTER --
WE DO SUPPORT THE THE THE GOALS
OF THE BILL --
IN FACT LAST SUMMER THE WATER
THROUGH WERE THAT WATER THIRTY
TOOK POSITION A CONDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
ON THE WATER FIX HOWEVER WAS
CONTINGENT UPON --
YOU KNOW THE FAIRNESS OF
ALLOCATION OF IS VERY CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOALS OF SB TWO OH FOUR
SO OUR OUR AMENDMENT WOULD SEEK
TO TAKE A JUST A BIT FURTHER IN
EXTENDING --
THE PROVISIONS IN THE BILL.
A RELATED --
TO PROVIDED ESTIMATED COST FOR
THE WATER CONTRACTORS TO EXTEND
THAT INFORMATION --
TO ALSO WHOLESALERS AND
RETAILERS AND CITY AGO IS A IS A
IS A WATER WHOLESALER SO THAT WE
WOULD BE PRIVY TO THAT
INFORMATION AS WELL.
VERY CONSISTENT WITH THE
POSITION THAT WOULD HELP --
CASINOS IN SUPPORT ANY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IT WOULD JUST YEAH DUDE DO YOU
GUYS CAN SCREW CHIN MAKE ROOM
AND THEN WE'LL WE'LL SWAP BACK
OUT IF NEED BE THANK YOU MA'AM.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
MORE.
GOOD MORNING --
GERMAN CERTAIN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JENNIFER
PIERRE AND I'M THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY THIS MORNING TO
TESTIFY.
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS IS A
NOT FOR FROM NOT FOR PROFIT
ORGANIZATION AND WE REPRESENT
TWENTY SEVEN OF THE TWENTY NINE
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES THAT
CONTRACT.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES FOR STATE WATER
PROJECT.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE STAFF ANALYSIS AND THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT CAME
OUT LIKE LATE LAST WEEK --
IF ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR --
THE OUTLINE A PATH FORWARD FOR
AMENDMENTS AND ADDRESS A NUMBER
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WE
ORIGINALLY HAD.
SO BASED ON THOSE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS I'M JUST GOING TO
LIMIT MY COMMENTS SO WHERE WE
HAVE REMAINING CONCERNS.
SO AS BEFORE --
TO FOR TOUCHES ON TWO COMPONENTS
RELATED TO TRANSPARENCY.
THE FIRST IS ON CERTAIN
AMENDMENTS A LONG TERM WATER
SUPPLY CONTRACTS THAT GOVERN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND THE PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES.
THESE ARE LONG TERM CONTRACTS
THEY DEAL ISSUES LIKE COST
ALLOCATION AND WATER ALLOCATION
AND NOT THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT OR ITS MAINTENANCE.
THE SECOND COMPONENT AND WHICH
IS THE FOCUS OF MY REMARKS AS
THE FOCUS ON THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR --
TRIGGER FOR THE DELTA CONVEYANCE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY.
OR AS WE CALL IT THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE AUTHORITY.
THE CONTRACTS AT THE DELTA
CONVEYANCE UTHORITY WOUD ENTER
INTO OUR FOR THE PLANNING AND
DESIGN OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
FIX THEY WOULD NOT.
BE RELATED TO ANY OF THE DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT THEY ARE REALLY
RELATED TO THE CONSTRUCTION
OPERATION SCHEDULE.
THE AUTHORITY WITH AN AGREEMENT
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES HAS --
HAS THE HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THE REMAINING
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION ALL OF
THE COSTS THE DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION ARE BORNE BY THE
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES WHO WILL
BENEFIT FROM IT.
THE AGENCY THAT HAS BEEN FORMED
THE DCA IS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY BIG.
GIVE ME MADE UP OF OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND THEY CONDUCT ALL
THEIR MEETINGS AND PUBLIC WITH A
COURT IN ACCORDANCE WITH
APPLICABLE LAWS AND ALL THEIR
AGENDAS STAFF PRESENTATIONS
MATERIALS ETCETERA ARE POSTED ON
THE WEBSITE.
THE DELAY THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT --
BILL WOULD CAUSE AN INCREASE IN
THE PROJECT BY REQUIRING.
A CONTRACT --
IMPLEMENTATION TO BE DELAYED.
WATER FIX WOULD BE FUNDED LIKE I
SAID BY THE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES.
AND THE COSTS THAT WOULD BE
POTENTIALLY INCREASE THROUGH
THESE DELAYS WOULD BE BORNE BY
THE RATE PAYERS AND THERE'S
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT DO RECEIVE
STATE WATER PROJECT WATER
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AS DRAFTED SB TWO OH FOUR WOULD
IMPOSE ON THE AUTHORITY WHEN
ISSUE IN CONTRACTS THAT THIS
ADDITIONAL TWO MONTH DELAY IN A
VERY PUBLIC A LONG PROCESS.
THE IDC A GIVEN ITS PUBLIC
NATURE IS SUBJECT TO PUBLIC
BIDDING REQUIREMENTS AND THAT
USUALLY TAKES ABOUT FOUR TO FIVE
MONTHS ALREADY.
SO THEN ADDING AN ADDITIONAL TWO
MONTHS BEFORE THE AUTHORITY
COULD EXECUTE A CONTRACT.
OF IS UNDUE DELAY.
THIS WOULD INHIBIT THE DAY TO
DAY OPERATIONS OF THE AUTHORITY
ITSELF.
ADDITIONALLY.
THERE IS A REFERENCE TO AQUOTE
UNQUOTE CONVENIENCE PROJECT AND
WE THINK THAT COULD BE VAGUE AND
LEAD TO CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT IS
COVERED BY THIS BILL.
WE UNDERSTAND THE PURPOSE IS TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA WATER FIX OR
SUSPECT X. EXCESS THEIR PROJECT.
AND FOR THAT REASON WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE L<c.cyan>G. TO</c>
APPLY TO CONVEYANCE PROJECT THAT
WOULD REQUIRE A CHANGE IN PLANET
AVERSION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WATER RIGHTS.
AND THIS WOULD PROVIDE THE
SPECIFICITY AND COVER WATER FIX
OR ANY OF ITS ASSESSED SUCCESSOR
PROJECTS.
AND WHEN TO MORE POINT PLEASE
I'M UNDERSTANDING CENTERED ON
DESIRE FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY WE
URGE FURTHER AMENDMENTS FOR THE
SECTION COVERING THE DC I AM
THAT WOULD PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ON THE PERSPECTIVE
BASIS AND WOULD NOT IMPACT THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS OR BECAUSE
UNNECESSARY DELAYS.
WITH THE DEATH OF THE LÏNG
WOULD BE AMENDED TO DELETE THE
CONTRACT REQUIREMENT AROUND THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR CAT --
TRIGGER AND INSTEAD PROVIDE.
THE ANNUAL BUDGET IN DRAFT FORM
AND FINAL FORM.
THE THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND THE DCA THAT A LOT --
PROVIDE THAT WE INCLUDE THIS
BUDGET AND THAT THE BUDGET
INCLUDES INDIVIDUAL CONTRACT
ESTIMATES.
WITH A CONTINGENCY AMOUNTS OF
THE DRAFT AND FINAL VERSION OF
THAT WOULD COULD BE PROVIDED.
AND THIS IS BASICALLY SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE THINK IS BEING SOUGHT IN
SB TWO OH FOUR BUT WOULD ALSO
PROVIDE THIS INFORMATION EARLIER.
AND NOT DELAY THE CONTRACTING
PROCESS LASTED JUST WANT TO KNOW
THAT WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE
AMENDMENTS --
PRESENTED BY THE SAN DIEGO WATER
AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHERS NOT POSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AT MANNING ON
BEHALF OF THE MOJAVE WATER
AGENCY IT'S PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TODAY IN FRONT OF YOU ON YOUR
FIRST --
DAYS CHAIR THANK YOU --
I HAVE SAT IN THIS CHAIR DOZENS
OF TIMES SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND NINE WHEN CENTER
COVER EURO WHOSE AND IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND OTHER MEMBERS --
HELPED --
DRAFT AND REWRITE CALIFORNIA
WATER LAW CALL THE DELTA REFORM
AT WHICH IS STYLISH THE CO EQUAL
GOALS AND CREATED A WHOLE NEW
PROCESS FOR REVIEWING THE WATER
FIX AND IMPLEMENTING IT.
ODD SINCE THAT TIME I COULD DO
MISTER TO TOLLWAYS PART AND HE
COULD DO MINE.
BECAUSE MISTER NATOLI WITH --
WHO I RESPECT VERY MUCH --
AND THE THE RESTORE THE DELTA
VOTES AND THE DELTA COUNTIES
COALITION HAVE.
SUPPORTED AND SPONSORED.
WELL OVER THIRTY BILLS I LOST
COUNT. TO STOP.
DELAY OR MAKE MORE COSTLY THE
WATER FIX --
AND THAT IS THEIR RIGHT.
BUT WE SHOULD SEE THIS BILL AS
AND MR TOLD ME MADE VERY CLEAR.
THEY ARE OPPOSED TO THE WATER
FIX THIS IS NOT ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY.
THIS IS ABOUT ANOTHER EFFORT TO
DELAY AND MAKE MORE COSTLY AND
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE I
UNDERSTAND THAT --
BUT WE SHOULD BE CLEAR
[inaudible]
THAT FIRST.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATE MONEY
FOR THE WATER FIX [inaudible]
THE DVR --
NOTE STATE MONEY IS SPENT ON THE
WATER FIXES MAR FACT IF YOU GO
BACK AND READ THE TWO THOUSAND
NINE LEGISLATION.
YOU PRO HIM IT IS.
A PENNY.
OF STATE MONEY TO BE SPENT ON
THE WATER FIX AND YOU HAVE ALSO
DONE A JAILER COLLIDED.
SPONSORED BY THE SAME FOLKS HERE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL TO MAKE
SURE THAT NOT A PENNY WAS SPENT.
AND IT ISN'T IT'S ALL RIGHT
PAYER MONEY IT OVERSEE THIS
BECAUSE IT'S LOCAL RATEPAYERS
LOCAL BOARDS GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS JUST LIKE MR NATOLI.
FIT ON THE MOJAVE WATER AGENCY
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
AND ALL THE AGENCIES THAT ARE
MAKING A CONSCIOUS CHOICE. TO
FUND THIS PROJECT BECAUSE IT
BENEFITS THE RATE PAYERS.
WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH A REVIEW
PROCESS THROUGH THE STATE WATER
BOARD.
THEIR PUBLIC HEARINGS WHICH WERE
REFERRED [inaudible]
TO TRANSPARENCY.
WE HAVE TO GET FISH AND WILDLIFE
PERMITS ESA PERMITS TRANSPARENCY.
WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH SEEK WHAT
ANY BY.
TRANSPARENCY.
AND YOU CREATED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND NINE LONG.
THE BILL TO REFORM ACT THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL THE NEW
AGENCY SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED
TO REVIEW.
THE WATER FIX FOR CONSISTENCY
WITH THE DELTA PLAN WOULD YOU
TOLD THEM THEY HAD TO DO.
TRANSPARENCY.
SO RATHER THAN A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY WERE TEN YEARS
AFTER TWO THOUSAND NINE AND WE
STILL HAVEN'T PUT A SHOVEL IN
THE GROUND.
I WOULD SAY.
PERHAPS WE HAVE TOO MUCH
TRANSPARENCY.
PERHAPS WE NEED TO BUILD
SOMETHING AT SOME POINT.
HAVING SAID THAT OF COURSE WERE
OPEN TO TRANSPARENCY IF THAT
ISN'T ENOUGH.
BUT JUST A FEW STATISTICS.
THERE HAVE BEEN TEN THOUSAND
FACTSHEETS EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS
IT CETERA DISTRIBUTED OR
COMMENTS RECEIVE THEIR BEEN
THREE HUNDRED FORTY ONE DAYS OF
PUBLIC HEARINGS.
THERE ARE HOWEVER THE BEEN SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY WORKGROUP MEETINGS.
AT CETERA ET CETERA ET CETERA ON
THIS PROJECT SO --
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY.
THAT YOU KNOW IMPOSING FURTHER
DELAY AND FOR THE COSTS ON THE
PROJECT IS NOT APPROPRIATE IF
THERE'S A LEGITIMATE OVERSIGHT
NEED.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS DONE BY THE
WAY [inaudible]
I'D SAY.
AT LEAST ONE HEARING YEAR WITH
MISTER O'CONNOR AS CONSULTANT.
AT LEAST ONCE EVERY YEAR SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND WE WELCOME
THAT WE'VE BEEN HERE WE'VE
ANSWERED THE QUESTIONS.
A GOVERNOR NEWSOME NOW HAS
SPOKEN TO THE PROJECT --
SO YOU KNOW WE'RE OPEN BUT AT
SOME POINT WE THINK ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH AND FOR THAT REASON WE
OPPOSE AND WE ALSO OPPOSE THE
SAN DIEGO MINUTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
OTHERS OPPOSED.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS BOARD BROOM
REPRESENTING THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT --
WHICH DELIVERS STATE WATER
PROJECT WATER TO TWO MILLION BAY
AREA RESIDENTS AND THOUSANDS OF
SILICON VALLEY JOB CREATING
BUSINESSES.
OUR BOARD ARE ELECTED BOARD
VOTED TO TAKEN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THIS BILL WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
WE SUPPORT TRANSPARENCY.
HOWEVER WE OPPOSE DELAY AND THIS
IS THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
YOUR MEMBERS JACK WALK ON BEHALF
OF THE KERN COUNTY WATER AGENCY
IN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
ASSOCIATE OUR OUR COMMENTS FOR
THOSE OF THE PREVIOUS TWO
WITNESSES AND APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE COMMITTEE
IT'S ENCOURAGING TO TAKE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT'S ALL BE ON A B..
S. QC ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER AS WELL AS THE
OTHER SAN GABRIEL AND WD A WE
OPPOSE THANK YOU OKAY VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN STERN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON KATHY VIA
TELEWORK METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
COMMENTS OF THE WITNESSES THT
WERE HERE TESTIFYING TODAY AND
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
INCREASING COSTS THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND DELAYING THE
CONTRACTS.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
I GUILT WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND I'D LIKE TO ECHO
THE CONCERNS OF THE FOLKS WITH
BROKEN IN OPPOSITION APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS --
AND APPRECIATE THAT YOU'LL BE
WORKING WITH US [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE RECEIVERS ON BEHALF THE MISS
WATER DISTRICT ORANGE COUNTY LOS
VIRGINS WATER DISTRICT OPPOSED
IN PRINT VERSION OF THE BILL.
VERY GOOD THANKS THE MORNING
BATH A LOSS SO ON BEHALF OF
CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES
AGENCY OPPOSE LESS AMENDED --
SUPPORT THE COMMENTS OF
METROPOLITAN THE CONTRACTORS
GOOD THANK YOU.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THE BIG WITH HER REDUCES HIS FOR
THE UPPER SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU SIR ANY OTHERS IN
SEEING NONE MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS YOU MADE A JUMP IN
FIRST [inaudible]
ANYONE.
SENATOR CAFIERO.
WELL I'LL JUMP IN BECAUSE I WAS.
UNFORTUNATELY AROUND IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE WHEN IT WAS ALL
SET UP AND I JUST I'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH THIS AND
APPRECIATE THE WHAT SENATOR DODD
IS TRYING TO DO HERE BUT QUITE
FRANKLY --
I'M CONCERNED WITH THE DELAY AND
THE CRADDICK.
REVIEW AND REVIEW AND REVIEW AND
I'VE I'VE SEEN THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
BLOCK THEM OUT AND IT APPEARS AS
IF THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE
GETTING RID OF THE DELAY PART OF
IT -- AND IF
THAT'S TRUE THEN THAT MAKES ME
FEEL A LITTLE BIT MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT BUT I GIVEN
THAT IT.
EVERYTHING IS PART OF A PUBLIC
PROCESS I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS MISSING WHERE
WHERE DO.
AND I'M.
I UNDER STAFF TO READING THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL I UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THE CONCERN WITH CAN AUTOMATIC
PILOT YOUDON'T KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON IN YOU THERE'S THERE'S
NOT THAT REVIEW BUT I'M JUST
WONDERING WE ALWAYS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BRING THE MEN AND TO
ASK.
QUESTIONS I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF.
WHY WE NEED THIS AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT IN TIME GIVEN?
IT WAS MY UNDERSTANDING OF THE
AMENDMENTS IF YOU TAKE THEM IS
THAT.
IT IS IT TAKES OUT THE NINETY
DAY.
DELAY.
AND IT ALSO --
IT ALSO.
IT YEAH IT'S A NINETY DAY DELAY
AND THAT ON SITE AND THE AND
TAKING IT OUT OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS AS WELL.
I'M GONNA LET MY WITNESS --
RESPONDED THIS BUT BEFORE HE
DOES THE I TAKE EXCEPTION TO MR
MANNING'S.
YOUR ASSERTION THAT I AM NOT FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND THAT --
WHAT I WANT TO DO IS MAKE THIS
PROJECT MORE COSTLY OR STOP THE
PROJECT ALTOGETHER NOTHING COULD
BE FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH OTHER
MAYBE ADVOCATES?
THAT THAT IS WHY THEY'RE
SUPPORTING THIS BUT THE REASON I
BIT BRING THIS BILL FORDIS
BECAUSE THE OTHER MEMBES THAT
ARE IN THE DELTA AREA WE FOUND
IT JUST NEXT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER.
QUESTIONS FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS
DURING THIS WHOLE WATER FIX
PROCESS.
AND FRANKLY --
YOU KNOW IF IT WEREN'T --
FOR THE JBL SEE AND THEIR
ACTIONS AT THE END THE SESSION
LAST YEAR --
THIS THING MIGHT HAVE GONE --
FOR THE FURTHER AND THEN IT DID
AND FRANKLY A LOT OF THE
OBJECTIONS FROM --
THE ADVOCATES JUST WEREN'T
ADDRESS --
WE JUST FELT LIKE THERE NEEDS TO
BE SOME LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE THAT'S WHY I TOOK THE
AMENDMENTS.
I DON'T WANT ANY STATE PROJECTS
TO BECOME MORE EXPENSIVE FOR OUR
RATE PAYERS.
VIEWS LET'S FACES LEGISLATORS.
OUR CONSTITUENTS OUR RATE PAYERS
AND WE'RE NOT LOOKING TO HAVE
THEIR COSTS GO UP OR HAVE YOU
KNOW TAKE THE PROJECT --
OUT YOU KNOW OUT LONGER.
BUT I WOULD JUST ECHO AS EARLY
AS THE CENTER DAHLE COMMENTS IN
IN SAY THAT.
BECOME AS RELATIVE TO A PUBLIC --
PROCESS THOSE ARE ALL ACCURATE
AND NOT WITH ANY DISPUTE ABOUT
THAT BUT THINK THE ARGUE ABOUT
GREATER TRANSPARENCY ANSWER THE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND I KNOW
SOME OF YOU SURELY HAVE SEEN YOU
HERE BEFORE --
YOU KNOW JUST LEGISLATIVE BODIES --
IN IN IN THE PAST AND AS MUCH AS
WE MAY NOT LIKE THE PROJECT WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A
PROCESS IN THIS ONE WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY THIS LEGISLATURE AND
DID THIS COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY.
MINISTRATION INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA THE AUTHORITIES --
VESTED IN THEM TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS BUT
THERE.
YEAH AT STAKE IS CERTAINLY IS
OUR IMPACTS TO A MET MEAL FOLKS
A WITH THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT. TO ARGUE
THAT TRANSPARENCY IF IT'S NOT
GOING TO RESULT IN UNDUE DELAY
AND OR UNDUE COST OR WRITTEN TO
ME SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
COUNTER TO TO GOOD GVERNMENT IN
FROM THE STANDPOINT OF THAT
COMMON SENSE OF THIS BILL.
I THINK IT REDUCES TO SOMETHING
THAT IS MASSIVE IT WILL BE A
GENERATIONAL IT WILL BE --
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE WITH US
FOR A LONG LONG TIME AND SO
THEREFORE CERTAINLY ALL OF US
HAVE A STAKE IN THIS
CALIFORNIA'S BUT WE'RE ASKING --
THINK WITH THIS BILL IS RUNNING
SUPPORT THIS BILL THAT
TRANSPARENCY IF YOU KNOW IF IT
ALLOWS FOR FOLKS HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING WITH AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH THAT WE THINK
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
THE ISSUE IS FOR ME IS I'M
ALWAYS FOR TRANSPARENCY AND I
GET IT IT'S IT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THE CONCERN I HAVE.
IS -- IS A
REPORT. FOR REPORTS SAKE WHERE --
PORCH WE'RE JUST SETTING UP MORE
AND MORE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO BE --
WHERE THERE'S THERE THERE'S A
COST EVERY TIME YOU DO --
ONE OF THESE THINGS AND SO I'M
NOT SAYING I'M NOT FOR
TRANSPARENCY I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IF YOU'VE GOT ALL OF
THESE IF YOU'RE DOING A SEQUEL
YOU'RE DOING ANY BY YOUR YOU'VE
GOT.
A JPA THAT'S GOT --
PUBLIC RESPONSIBILITIES FOR
REPORTING AND FOR SHARING
INFORMATION AND HAVING PUBLIC
HEARINGS WHETHER IT WHETHER
WE'RE ADDING ONE MORE LEVEL --
THAT THAT DOESN'T GET US TO
WHERE WE REALLY WANT TO GO AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S THE BEST WAY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO GET INFORMATION.
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
TALK TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS ABOUT
IT BECAUSE FRANKLY --
THE JPA DOES DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATORS RIGHT
AND SO THE INFORMATION THERE
THEY MAY NOT BE GETTING THE
INFORMATION THAT PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND ARE GETTING SO I'M JUST.
WE HAVE ALREADY IN THE STATE
THAT PUSHED MULTIPLE.
ROCKER SEES IF YOU WILL THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT AT ALL THIS IS I THINK
IT'S JUST A STRAIGHT FORWARD.
RESPONSE --
TO SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN THAT HAVE CREATED A
MAJOR PROBLEMS IN THE AREAS THAT --
WE REPRESENT AND THEN BEYOND --
THAT FOR REPAIRS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FRANKLY
THE JBL SEE --
YOUR LAST YEAR AND WHAT THEY DID --
DEAL WITH THIS.
IF YOU KNOW THAT PROCESS WORKED
AND SO WE SAW THIS AS A GOOD
COMMONSENSE A SITUATION FOR YET
ANOTHER LEVEL OF REVIEW --
BY IT THE AREA AND IT'S NOT LIKE
THEY HAVE VETO POWER IT'S JUST
GIVING THE LEGISLATURE SOME.
SORT OF REVIEW.
IN SHORT SO SORRY SO YOU GOOD.
I THINK WE HAD SENATOR HUESO NAY
AND WE'VE CENTER HUESO NEXT
HERTZBERG NEXT NOW AYE AYE.
COME TO YOU FIRST SIR COME BACK
TO HERTZ BERG IN THE MID DECK
MISTER BORDERS.
SENATOR JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
SOME COMMENTS YOU MADE BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT OF REFERENCE PEOPLE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BECAUSE
THEY OPPOSE THE PROJECT AND THAT
THAT WASN'T NECESSARILY YOUR
AIMED.
MY QUESTION USED TO USE SUPPORT
THE PROJECT.
NO I DO NOT SO IF YOU HAD YOUR
WAY YOU WOULD NOT --
WEIGHTS COOK OR TO SPUR THIS
PROJECT WOULD NOT MOVE FORWARD I
I'M STUDYING THE NEW PROPOSAL
THAT --
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S PUT ON THE
TABLE I THINK IT REFLECTS A MUCH
MORE RESPONSIBLE --
WAY OF LOOKING THE DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS AND WILL ANXIOUSLY
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THIS GOVERNOR.
ON A FIX BECAUSE YOU KNOW AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
WE CAN'T JUST BE OPPOSED TO
EVERYTHING THAT COMES ACROSS WE
HAVE ISSUES WITH AGRICULTURE WE
HAVE ISSUES WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
POPULATED AREAS AND WE'RE ALL
ONE STATE AND WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND THE RIGHT
SOLUTION AND SO GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S PROPOSAL OF ONE PIPE
VERSUS.
TO WOULD BEGIN HOLDEN PROCESS.
SO WHATEVER WE'VE DONE IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS WOULD BE PRETTY
MUCH [inaudible]
OF BUT I I CAN SEE COULD BE
SOMEWHAT HELPFUL BUT WE WERE
BASICALLY GOING TO START A NEW
PROCESS ON THIS PROBLEM.
WELL I I THINK THAT'S THE
GOVERNOR'S BRAGA OF IS THE DULY
ELECTED GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T
HAVE.
ANY SAY IN THAT MATTER AS A AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
WELL WE HAVE A SAFE AS A
AND WE CAN PROPOSE FIXES ON OUR
END.
AND I'M JUST YOU KNOW SITTING
HERE --
PRIVY TO THIS PROBLEM AND I I
UNDERSTAND IS A MASSIVE PROBLEM
NOT A BIG PROBLEM ITS MASSIVE.
AND AS WE TALK ABOUT --
THIS SOLUTION PROTECT
POTENTIALLY HINDERING CERTAIN
FARMLANDS I ALSO KNOW ONE NON
SOLUTION COULD HINDER.
LOTS MORE LAND BECAUSE OF SALT
WATER INTRUSION.
AND THAT.
AND AND THE LIKE OF OF BECAUSE
BY -- IT YOU
KNOW INTRODUCING.
SALTWATER INVADE A SPECIES UP OF
FURTHER INTO INTO THE RIVER
WHICH IS ALREADY HAPPENING YOU
ALREADY SEEN.
A REDUCTION AND SALMON RUNS YOU
ALREADY SEEN A REDUCTION IN
CERTAIN ENDEMIC SPECIES HERE
BECAUSE OF THE THE INTRODUCTION
OF OF OF OF MORE MARINES
SPEECHES WERE NEVER.
YOU KNOW I'M.
I HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS ABOUT
US KIND OF CHANGING DIRECTION
AFTER TEN YEARS I HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PROBLEM NOT
THE TEXT --
BUT I ALSO HAVE A LOT OF
CONCERNS THAT --
I TAKE IT COULD TAKE TWO TO
THREE MONTHS TO GET INFORMATION
FROM THIS AGENCY.
MY QUESTION REGARDING THAT ISN'T
THERE -- ALL
OF A STATUTORY REQUIREMENT AND
HOW.
A GOVERNMENT AGENCIES NEED TO
RESPOND --
TO PUBLIC RECORD REQUESTS ISN'T
THAT LIKE A THIRTY DAY --
RULE THEY HAVE TO RESPOND WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS [inaudible]
THE PROJECT.
WHEN WE GO THROUGH THESE
PROCESSES WHAT HAPPENS AS WE
RECEIVE LETTER AFTER LETTER FOR
CONTINUATION?
OP PARTICULARLY WHEN --
DECISIONS ARE BEING PROCESSED --
REGARDING --
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS OVER WATER
AVAILABILITY AND SUPPLY.
AND SO WHICH OR IS THERE NOT A
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT THERE IS
THERE IS A STATUTORY REQUIREMENT
HOWEVER.
THEY CAN RESPOND BACK AND OR THE
INFORMATION THAT'S REQUESTED OR
IT HAS TO GO THROUGH REVIEW FOR
THEIR ATTORNEYS THAT THEY CAN
pDELAY.
OUR LAST PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST COULD DIED.
A INCLUDED SOMETHING LIKE SIX OR
SEVEN DELAYS --
WITH THIS MODEL CHANGES AFFECT.
PART PART OF WHAT THIS BILL WILL
DO THIS BILL CHANGE THAT THAT
BILL THIS BILL WILL NOT CHANGE
THAT BUT IT DOES SOMETHING ELSE
FOR US.
IN THAT IS.
THE PROCESSES ARE ALL MATCHING
UP.
WHAT IS REVEALED AT THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
ABOUT COSTS DOESN'T MATCH UP
WITH WHAT YOU SEE IN CONTRACTS?
DOESN'T MATCH UP WITH WATER
SUPPLY DECISIONS BEING DISCUSSED
BY WATER DISTRICTS.
AND WHAT THIS WOULD ALLOW IS
SOME OVERSIGHT TIME.
AT SOME TRANSPARENCY SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN EVALUATE TO SEE HOW
THE PIECES ARE FITTING TOGETHER.
BUT IF THIS BILL DOESN'T RESOLVE
YOUR PROBLEM WHY DO YOU BRING
THAT UP AS AN EXAMPLE BECAUSE
CONTRARY TO WHAT PEOPLE SAY IN
PEGA SAYS THAT RESTORE THE DELTA.
WE ARE VERY MUCH CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ENTIRE PROJECT.
SERVING PEOPLE WITH AFFORDABLE
AND RELIABLE WATER AS MUCH AS WE
ARE ABOUT WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
WITH IN THE DELTA THIS ISN'T AN
EITHER OR SITUATION.
WE HAVE TO GET IT RIGHT.
ADD TO GET IT RIGHT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND.
WATER SUPPLY WATER DELIVERY AND
COSTS AND RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO
WAY TO EVALUATE ALL THOSE PIECES
TOGETHER.
WELL THERE'S A WAY IF WE TAKE
THE INITIATIVE TO EVALUATE ALL
THOSE PIECES TOGETHER.
DOES THIS BILL.
REQUIRE THAT THEY'LL BE
EVALUATED TOGETHER.
IT HELPS THE PROCESS IT'S NOT ITDOESN'T REQUIRED EITHER SO IT
DOESN'T ISN'T NECESSARILY GONNA.
CONTRIBUTOR THAT EITHER.
RIGHT IT HELPS THE PROCESS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
BUT I I THINK GENERALLY YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE IF WE'RE GOING TO GET
TO A SOLUTION WE BETTER START
WORKING ON IT.
ANNA AND I WOULD RATHER SEE.
SOME EFFORT PUT INTO.
RESOLVING THIS PROBLEM.
THIS IS WHERE ALL OUR EFFORTS I
MEAN THIS IS.
YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN WHEN
GOVERNMENT IS CRITICIZED.
FOR FOR THIS.
OF OF YOU KNOW.
A HOT POTATO AROUND.
AND KICKING THE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD AND WHATEVER --
IN ANALOGY WANNA USE FOR THAT.
I MEAN THIS IS KIND OF AN
EXAMPLE THAT I HATE TO BE PART
OF THAT PROCESS I REALLY DO THIS
IS A MAJOR.
PROBLEM FACING THIS IS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER.
IT BASE IN OUR STATE AND THIS IS
THIS AFFECTS OUR ECONOMY AFFECTS
OUR OUR ENVIRONMENT AFFECTS
PEOPLE'S HEALTH.
THIS IS A MAJOR PROBLEM AND AND
AND AND IF THIS IS OUR RESPONSE
TO IT I MEAN I'M A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED.
SORRY SORRY SENATOR DODD BUT I
MEAN CENTER CENTER WITH ALL THE
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT --
TO FOR THE OPPOSITION --
TO ASSERT THAT --
A SIXTY DAY PROTECT --
IT GOING BACK AND LOOKING.
LOOKING BACK AT THIS THING
CREATED A TEN YEAR PROCESS --
IS FRANKLY ABSURD --
THE THE REALITY IS IT'S A TEN
YEAR PROCESS BECAUSE IT'S
INCREDIBLY EXPENSIVE IT DOESN'T
DELIVER THE WATER THAT IS
SUGGESTED DOES IN IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE RISK TO AN ALREADY
FRAGILE DELTA.
REGION.
AND SO THE REALITY IS MOVING
FORWARD AGAIN FOR RATEPAYERS AND
ALSO FOR THE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
IMPACT IN AROUND THE DELTA WHO I
REPRESENT --
WE FEEL GOING FORWARD THIS IS A
TOOL WITHOUT.
THE INCREASING COST WITHOUT.
THE PUTTING MORE DELAYS IN THE
SYSTEM THAT MAKES --
THE COMMUNITIES THAT THE THAT I
SERVE FEEL BETTER ABOUT THE
PROCESS SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
INCREDIBLY CORRECT IN TERMS OF
IT'S NOT THE BE ALL END.
IN IT AND AND ALL.
FRANKLY WE WERE GOING TO COME
HERE TODAY WITH SOMETHING LIKE
THAT THAT WOULD SIMPLY WASTE
YOUR TIME THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
SOLUTION. TO A VERY COMPLEX --
THE PROBLEM AND WE YOU KNOW JUST.
THE NEED THE LEGISLATURE'S
SUPPORT OF THIS --
YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DANGERS ARE BOTH
SIDES OF THIS EQUATION AND AND
AND THAT'S EQUALLY IMPORTANT TO
US AS WELL THANK YOU.
I JUST GENERALLY MY LAST COMMENT --
YOU KNOW YOU ALWAYS BEEN A VERY
WELL BALANCED SENATOR.
AND AND WILLING TO TAKE ON SOME
OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES ON OUR
STATE AND THIS IS DEFINITELY.
ONE I THINK THIS BILL MAKES A
LOT OF WORK BUT I THINK.
YOU'RE THE YOU'RE THE RIGHT
PERSON AND TAKE THIS ISSUE ON IF
IF YOU IF YOU REALLY INTEND TO
AND I WANNA SUPPORT IN DOING
THAT.
I CAN FOR THE MEANTIME --
ALL SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY SO
YOU CAN CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
BUT YOU HAVE A LOT OF WORK AHEAD
OF YOU.
AS USUAL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO --
CENTER HERTZBERG I HAD AND THEN
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
WHITE.
IT IS THIS NOTION OF THE
CONTRACTS IN THE TERMS OF THE
CONTRACTS WHY.
CAN'T.
SENATOR YOU ACHIEVE THE SAME
TRANSPARENCY RESULTS BY
BASICALLY DISCLOSING THE BUDGETS
PROPOSING THE BUDGET IS CLOSING
ALL THE INFORMATION.
RATHER THAN HAVING THE CONTRACT
REVIEW PERIOD BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE JUST DID.
A NUDE COMMITTEE WITH THE JOINT
COMMITTEE WITH THE BUDGET
LOOKING AT THESE CONTRACTS AND
STUFF.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AND AS
LEGISLATURE'S VERY OF OF A
SINGLE TO EVERY PROVISION OF
THESE CONTRACTS AND THE LIKE
CAN'T YOU WOULD SHE THE
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS THAT
YOU ARE SEEKING TO DO.
WITHOUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES NOW THE ARGUMENT IS.
IF IN FACT IS THE OTHER SIDE
MAKES THE POINT YOU KNOW I MEAN
LIKE SAYS.
I'M AN LA GUY HI SO I I SUPPORT
THE WATER FIX IN A BIG WAY AND
JUST WATCH AND THEY'LL.
DISCLOSE THAT UP FRONT SO SO BUT
IT'S TO THE QUESTION IT HAS BEEN
THIS TENSION THAT WE'VE SEEN
EXIST SINCE THE DAYS OF BUT
JERRY BROWN'S --
PERIPHERAL CAN THAT STUFF AND SO
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN THIS CHALLENGE
OF WE READ THANKS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA STEALING YOUR
PRISTINE WATER.
THE END AND I GET THAT.
BUT WE'RE DOWN THE ROAD I THINK
THAT WITH THE GOVERNOR DID TO
REDUCE IT TO ONE TUNNEL YOU KNOW
THERE WAS TO BE PLAYED AT THE IS
A SIGNIFICANT SHIFT --
IN IN WHERE WE ARE THE QUESTION
IS HOW CAN YOU --
IT HERE TO ON THE ONE HAND THE
SENSITIVITIES THAT YOU
APPROPRIATELY EXPRESS. TO YOUR
CONSTITUENTS LIKE YOU THEY ASK
YOU QUESTIONS YOU WANT TO GIVE
THEM ANSWERS FAIR QUESTION AND
NOT DELAY THE PROJECT IF IN FACT
THE PURPOSE OF THIS.
IS NOT -- TO
JUST TO LET AND BECAUSE ANOTHER
WRENCH IF IT'S JUST TRANSPARENCY
WHAT'S A LESSER INCLUDED
APPROACH. TO ACHIEVE
TRANSPARENCY CRITICAL OBJECTIVE
WITHOUT A DELAY THE IDEA WHERE
IF YOU WERE DISCLOSED AS WAS
SUGGESTED.
YOU KNOW ALL THE BUDGET ALL THE
CONTRACTS DISCLOSE EVERYTHING.
BUT THE PROCESS OF A BUS IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAVING THIS REVIEW.
AND THE IN A RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE JP EIGHT TO ME --
I LOOK AT IT AS A NECESSARY
LAYER YOU CAN ACHIEVE YOUR
OBJECTIVES BY JUST SIMPLY
DISCLOSING ALL OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS WITHOUT A DELAY.
AS ONE HEAR YOUR THOUGHTS.
WALLS IS WE HEARD TESTIMONY
TODAY --
THOSE DO NOT THOSE DOCUMENTS
DON'T ALWAYS MATCH UP.
ADD --
BRINGING THAT BEFORE THE JBL SEE --
SEEMS TO BE.
A ONCE IN A LESS --
APPROACH --
TO GETTING TRANSPARENCY AND WE
ALSO.
MY FEELING WAS AS BY ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT WE TOOK OUT THE EXCESSIVE
DELAYS -- IN
THE PROCESS AND ALSO KNOCKED OUT --
THE EXCESSIVE COSTS WHAT WOULD
IT HELP AND I DON'T INTERRUPT
YOUR LANGUAGE WOULD HELP US TO
JUST RUN THROUGH VERY BRIEFLY
FOR THE MEMBERS HERE WHAT
EXACTLY THESE AMENDMENTS ENTAIL
THAT THEY'RE GREAT [inaudible]
OFF YEAH.
LET'S WALK THROUGH THOSE JUST
VERY BRIEFLY IT IS.
THEY ARE INSUFFICIENT ADMITTEDLY
FOR THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
METROPOLITAN MY HOBBY AND THE
OPPONENTS FROM MY UNDERSTANDING
STILL REMAIN OPPOSED.
EVEN WITH --
THE THE AMENDS BUT AT THE MOMENT
SAID SENATOR DODD IS ALREADY
COMMITTED TAKING FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
WOULD SET A A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR THRESHOLD ON THE THE
TYPES OF CONTRACTS THAT THE JEEP.
THE DEVICE.
YES FIVE MILLION DOLLAR THAT
THOSE WITH THAT THAT WOULD HAVE
TO YOUR REPORTED --
TO THE JAIL BC AND THE RELEVANT
POLICY COMMITTEES --
WE'VE WE WOULD BE STRIKING.
THE MAN.
THE THE THE SORT OF PRE
CONDITION ON ACTUALLY EXECUTING
THE CONTRACT. FOR LEGISLATIVE
HEARING TO OCCUR BEFORE THAT SO
THAT AGE THREE LOT INFORMATION
READY EXACTLY --
WE ELIMINATE THE NEED. TO TO
REPORT THEN ON THE A PERMANENT
TRANSFERS OF CONTRACTUAL WATER --
AS NOTED THE ANALYSIS.
MAYBE SORT OF ARBITRATOR
RELEVANT TO THE BROADER ISSUE
THAT THE SENATORS TRYING.
TO ACHIEVE --
AND THEN WE ALSO DO WOULD WOULD
WOULD ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT
ON WOULD HAVE WHAT IS PAGE FOUR
LINES LINES SEVEN THROUGH --
TWELVE AS SUBSECTIONS HE WHICH
WOULD -- BAR
THE WHO THE ORIGINAL WOULD HAVE
REQUIRED A LEGISLATIVE.
HEARING PRIOR TO EXECUTION OF
THAT LONG TERM SUPPLY AGREEMENT --
SO THAT'S THE THAT'S THE UICK
SUMMARY AND THE ISSUE I THINK
THAT WE'VE SORT OF HONED IN ON
HERE IS.
WHAT'S THE MOST MEANINGFUL KIND
OF TRANSPARENCY AND AND WHAT --
IF I DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH BUT WHAT IT SEEMS
LIKE THE PROPONENTS ARE ASKING
FOR SAYING.
WE WANT --
THE THE CONTRACTS THEMSELVES
BROUGHT FORTH AND THAT THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT REPORTED TO THIS
JAIL BE SEE THE ACTUAL.
DOCUMENTS THEMSELVES THE TERMS
CONDITIONS THERE IN.
HERE TO FOUR WE'VE WE'VE WORKED
WITH THE BUDGE STRUCTURES RIGHT
SO WE'VE ACTUALLY LOOKED AT OKAY
WHAT ARE THEY PUTTING INTO FOUR
BASE CONSTRUCTION IN TAKES
TUNNELS AND SORT OF LOOKING AT
SORT OF THE RESERVE A BREAK DOWN
OF WHAT THEY'RE PROJECTED BUDGET
AS WELL AS WHAT THEIR ACTUAL.
FINAL BUDGET IS AND THEN WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DRILL DOWN AND
WITHIN THAT AND SAY OKAY
SOMETHING LOOKS AMISS HERE YOUR
COST OF GOING UP YOUR COST OF
GONE WAY DOWN.
AND WE STILL HAVE THE POWER TO
LOOK AT THOSE.
UP TO THIS POINT WE REALLY
HAVEN'T HAD A REQUIREMENT LAW
SAYING PUT THE ACTUAL CONTRACTS
FOR TO THE JAIL BC SO.
HI I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S A MEANINGFUL KIND OF
TRANSPARENCY FOR US TO HAVE HOW
MUCH DOES THE LEAD PUMP WHAT IS
TMI AND WHAT IS NOT RIGHT WHAT
WHAT LIKE WHAT.
WHAT WHAT LEVEL IF WE GET A
STACK OF HUNDREDS OF CONTRACTS
IS THAT ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
USEFUL TO THE JAIL BC TO DO
OVERSIGHT --
TO THIS COMMITTEE VERSES SAY A
BUDGET DOCUMENT SO I I THINK
THAT'S SORT OF WHERE WE'VE WE'VE
LANDED POLICY.
I'LL COME BACK YES OR THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN IT AND THAT'S
THE QUESTION IS THIS THIS IS ONE
OF THESE AREAS I THINK.
WHERE THERE'S ENOUGH EYEBALLS ON
IT RIGHT THAT EVERY COMMA OF
EVERY CONTRACT EVERY DOLLAR IN
THE GAME IS GOING TO BE ANALYZED
BY THE OPPONENTS? TO THE PROCESS
RIGHT I MEAN THIS IS NOT A
SITUATION WHERE NOBODY'S PAYING
ATTENTION YOU GOT ALWAYS WATER
AGENCIES OUT THERE.
EVERYBODY IS IS IN THE PROCESS
SOTHE QUESTION BECOMES.
BOB GOOD FOLLOWING UP ON YOUR
YOUR YOUR ANALYSIS EXACTLY
CORRECT IS THAT OKAY.
IF EVERYBODY'S GONNA KNOW THAT
IS THERE A VENUE BY WHICH THEY
CAN BRING THAT TO SOMEBODY'S
ATTENTION AND DOES THE BRINGING
OF THE ATTENTION.
AS SENATOR CABALLERO TALKED
ABOUT BECAUSE THAT A STATUTORY
DELAY IN THE PROCESS.
BECAUSE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IS EVEN IF THERE IS NO PROBLEM
YOU'RE STILL GOING TO HAVE A
STATUTORY DELAY IN THE TIME LINE
WHEN THERE MIGHT NOT BE A NEED
TO HAVE.
ONE RIGHT AND SO IF YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE ALL THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY BELIEVE
ME THE ALARMS WILL SOUND YOU
KNOW THE POINT THAT WAS RAISED
THAT WE HAD MEETINGS EVERY.
HEARINGS EVERY YEAR ON THIS CON
ON THIS PART I DID THOSE
HEARINGS YOU KNOW SO I I
COMPLETELY AGREE AND TERMS OF
ANY CHALLENGES AND WE'RE ON IT
SO.
I DON'T KNOW A CENTER DOT I MEAN.
THERE IS LEGITIMACY TO THE
LARGER ARGUMENT IN MY JUDGMENT
THAT THERE HAS BEEN ATTENTION.
AND THAT THERE'S ALWAYS
SUSPICION ON BOTH SIDES JUST THE
WAY IT IS.
QUESTION IS HOW CAN YOU ACHIEVE
THE OBJECTIVE THAT YOU WANT TO
ACHIEVE AND AVOID THAT SUSPICION.
THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET TO
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN
[inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THOSE
COMMENTS CENTER ERTZBERG SENATE
JACKSON DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT
QUESTION.
I APOLOGIZE SAID.
I WASN'T ABLE TO BE HERE AS
BEING PUT THROUGH MY PACES IN
SENATOR DODD'S COMMITTEE --
SO -- I I
GUESS [inaudible]
THE ISSUE.
ARE THE ARE SENSIBLE ISSUE IS
ONE OF TRANSPARENCY.
BUT THERE'S MORE TO THIS --
AND SO I WOULD LIKE --
IF SOMEONE COULD SHARE WHAT THE
CONCERN IS BEYOND THE
TRANSPARENCY IS.
THE CENTER HERTZBERG INDICATED
YOU KNOW NOBODY TRUSTS ANYBODY.
I THINK THAT'S A FOR STATEMENT
WHETHER THERE'S HISTORICAL BASIS
FOR THAT ARE JUST IS IT IS THE
WAY IT IS.
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT WHAT IS
THE UNDERLYING REASON?
THAT YOU'RE HERE SEEKING THIS
TRANSPARENCY OR OR NG TO SEEK
THIS TRANSPARENCY THAT OTHERS
ARE SAYING NO.
WE NEED TO DO IT IN A DIFFERENT
WAY AT THE END OF THE DAY WHAT
IS THE WHAT IS THE ULTIMATE
CONSEQUENCE OF HOW AND WHETHER
WE WILL ACHIEVE THAT
TRANSPARENCY.
GREATEST CONCERN ON WHEN YOU.
LOOK AT THE EVALUATION OF STATE
WATER CONTRACT IS THAT THE WATER
DELIVERIES.
HAVE TO BE CERTAIN TO BE THERE
FOR THE BOND REPAYMENTS CAN
EVENTUALLY BE MADE.
THE CONTRACTS REVEAL.
THE WATER DELIVERIES AND THE
ALLOTMENTS.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT IS NORMALLY
LOOKED AT AS FAR AS REVENUES.
AND SO WHEN OF WHEN A CONTRACT
COMES IN THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME
TIME.
AREN'T WE BELIEVE FOR US TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
SO THAT THEY CAN ASK THE MEANING
FOR QUESTIONS --
OF THE CONTRACT [inaudible]
BECAUSE UNLESS THESE CONTRACTS
ARE.
APPROPRIATE AND MEANINGFUL WE
WON'T BE REPAYING THE BOND.
IS AND AND SO WHY ARE THE FOLKS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
NOT HAPPY WITH THIS BILL BUT YOU
FEEL YOU NEED TO BRING THIS BILL.
ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY.
WELL I FIGURED IT LIVES UP THE
COST WITH THE WATER DELIVERS
ASKS -- SHE
IS -- I
DISCUSSED.
AND I THINK IT'S NOT ONLY FOR
THE REPRESENTATIVES THAT
REPRESENT THE DELTA AREAS.
I THINK THIS IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT FOR LET'S SAID JULES
AND MODERATE SEEING DIEGO IN THE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE COSTS THAT
WATER IS SO WHEN THOSE RATES DO
GO OUT FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PROCESS.
THAT EITHER THE LEGISLATURE
KNOWS AND UNDERSTANDS --
EACH YEAH THAT IT CAN GET
REPRESENT ADEQUATELY REPRESENT.
YOU ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS SO
THERE'S A CONCERN THAT THE
INFORMATION IS NOT BEING
ACCURATELY RELAYED TO THE RATE
PAYERS.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK EVERYWHERE FRANKLY IS IS
THE IS A DETERMINATION THAT --
THE THAT HAS BEEN MADE.
BUT I THINK IT'S EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO TAT --
THE OLD.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THERE IS
RISK AND REWARDS IN EVERY
PROJECT.
AND I THINK THIS REALLY ALLOWS.
THE PUBLIC TO UNDERSTAND.
INTO A COMPREHENSIVE WAY THE
RISK AND REWARDS.
OF SUCH A PROJECT TO NOT ONLY
THE BROADER STATE --
MOVING FORWARD BUT ALSO TO THOSE
THAT ARE --
INTIMATELY IMPACTED IN THE DELTA
REGION.
AND SO YOU YOU'RE ASSUMING THAT
IF ALL THIS INFORMATION WERE
MADE KNOWN.
THAT THE THAT THE COST WELL IT
WHAT YOU WOULD PERCEIVE IS
LIKELY PROHIBITIVE WOULD BE MADE
KNOWN TO THE PEOPLE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT THEY WOULD
NOT WANT TO CONTINUE WITH THE
PROJECT OR PROMOTE THE PROJECT
BECAUSE THE COST IS TOO GREAT.
I WOULDN'T MAKE THAT IT
PRESUMPTION I WOULD ASSUME THAT
THE PUBLIC HAS THE RIGHT TO KNOW.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IT IS
RECEIVING FOR THE MONEY THAT'S
SPENT.
EVEN A SINGLE TUNNEL PROJECT
WILL BECOME.
WITH COST OVERRUNS INTEREST
REPAYMENTS AND BOND THAT --
AND AND OPERATIONS THE SECOND
LARGEST OR SECOND MOST EXPENSIVE
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT WHAT WAS
RELATED TO RATE PAYERS AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DOESN'T
MATCH WATER BOARD TESTIMONY.
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS.
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE AND JUST
A SMALL AMOUNT OF TIME.
HOW DOES THAT CONTRACT MATCH UP
WITH THESE OTHER PROCESSES SO
THAT WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE GETTING
FOR WHAT WE'RE PAYING?
SO THROUGH THE CHAIR COULD WE
HAVE.
A GOOD ONE OF THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS.
OF LEGISLATION FROM THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA --
SURE THEIR PERSPECTIVES I'M JUST
TRYING TO THEIR WITH WATER
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING MORE
THAN WHAT'S ON THE SURFACE.
THAT I I'M JAY WATER CONTRACTORS
ARE HERE YEAH WELL RIGHT I MEAN
IT'S SHOCKING SHOCKING I AM I AM
SHOCKED THE PERSPECTIVE IS OF
WHAT UNDER THE SURFACE.
FROM THE FOLKS WHO OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING I'M JENNIFER PAIR
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS --
THE CONTRACTS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT OUR FOR THROUGH THE DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY THEY
ONLY DEAL WITH DESIGN AND
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES AND NOT
AGENCY WOULD ACTUALLY BE SUNSET
IT AT WHEN THE CAR WATER FIXES
THAN BEING CONSTRUCTED.
THEY HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
WATER SUPPLY CONTRACT OR HOW
WATER IS DELIVERED OR WHEN IT'S
OPERATED OR HOW IT'S OPERATED
IT'S LITERALLY JUST AN AGENCY TO
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCT.
THE PROJECT AND IN A PUBLIC WAY
WITH A PUBLIC BOARD SO THAT IT
CAN PROVIDE MORE TRANSPARENCY.
SECOND I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THE ISSUE THIS WE STILL HAVE A
DELAY ISSUE THIS IS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR PROJECT.
PROBABLY EVEN WITH ONE TUNNEL.
AND AT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
INCREMENTS THAT IS GOING TO BE
AN EXCESSIVE ACTIVITY OF
BRINGING THAT IN FRONT OF YOU
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE SUGGESTING
THAT INSTEAD OF DOING.
INCREMENTAL FIVE MILLION DOLLAR --
SUBMITTALS THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
AN ANNUAL BUDGET WHICH ACTUALLY
IT DOES EXACTLY WHAT IT SEEMS AS
PURPOSE THOUGHT IS TO MARRY THE
TOTALITY OF THE ACTIVITIES GOING
ON WITH THE DCA.
WITH THE TOTALITY OF THE COSTS
IN THAT PARTICULAR YEAR I'D ALSO
LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT THE
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE GPA REQUIRES THAT WHEN
THERE IS A 5% INCREASE IN BUDGET.
OR MORE THAN A SIX MONTH DELAY
THERE'D BE ANOTHER --
DEVELOPMENT THAT COULD COME
BEFORE YOU AND THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED AND AND SOME OF OUR
AMENDMENT SO WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE IS THAT WHEN THERE ARE
CHANGES THAT OCCUR MORE THAN
ANNUALLY.
THOSE CAN COME BEFORE YOU AS
WELL [inaudible]
GOOD.
THANK YOU MUCH OF MUCH
APPRECIATED.
EXCELLENT --
SO WITHOUT FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE DíAS I WOULD WANT TO
DRILL DOWN ON ON SOME OF THE
SORT OF OUTSTANDING ISSUES WE DO
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND TAKEN THE THAT THE
AMENDMENTS --
BUT THE THE THE STATE
CONTRACTORS JUST POINTED OUT
THAT.
NOTHING IN THE THE CONTRACTS THE
TO BE SUBMITTED TO THE JAIL BC
UNDER THE CURRENT LANGUAGE WOULD
INCLUDE WATER SUPPLY YOUR
DELIVERY --
INFORMATION STRICTLY RELATED I
BELIEVE IT.
SAYS PLANNING DESIGN --
IN CONSTRUCTION I BELIEVE IN THE
NATURE THE CONTRACTUAL
AGREEMENTS SO FOR THE RECORD I I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE AND
IN TERMS ACHIEVING YOUR PURPOSES
HERE PROCEDURALLY.
MAYBE NOT SUBSTANTIVELY BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK WE CAN HAVE THAT.
BROADER SUBSTANTIVE DEBATE TODAY
AT LEAST IN THE CONFINES OF THIS
BILL BUT THOUGHTS ON THIS THIS
CONCEPT OF THE THE VALUE OF AN
ANNUAL BUDGET.
AND THEN USING THESE ARE PUBLIC
THAT THE CONTRACTS ARE PUBLIC
DOCUMENTS RIGHT IS SO WHAT
THEY'RE ALL ACCESSIBLE PUBLICLY
TO JUST WANT TO GET YOUR
PERSPECTIVE.
ON THIS WHICH SOUNDS LIKE A
REASON NO BUDGET BOTH IN DRAFT
FORM.
AS WELL AS A FINAL BUDGET.
AND TO TO MAKE THAT THE ITEM
THAT'S EITHER SUBMITTED TO THE
JAIL BC OR THAT WE YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A WATER COMMISSION SET UP
TO BY THE WAY IN ADDITION TO THE
TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT.
THAT -- DOES
THE ANNUAL REVIEW OF
CONSTRUCTION OPERATION OF THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM SO.
I'M I'M INTERESTED IN IN TRYING
TO FIND SOME SOLUTION HERE THAT
THAT MIGHT ACHIEVE YOUR PURPOSES
WITHOUT --
PUTTING FOR DOCUMENTS THAT
FRANKLY WE ARE GOING TO BE THAT
MEANINGFUL TO US IF WE'RE
EVALUATING HOW THE PROJECTS
GOING SO.
THOUGHTS ON THE DRAFT ANNUAL
LIKE SORT OF THE BUDGET
SUBMISSION.
YEAH WELL I I GUESS WHAT I'D
HAVE TO SAY IS --
IT -- THEY
MAY NOT BE THEY MAY NOT BE
IMPORTANT AS IT'S BEEN PRESENTED
HERE TODAY.
BUT IT WILL WHAT THEY MAY DO IS
THEY MAY TELL THE WHOLE STORY.
SO TO SPEAK AND LET ME JUST SAY.
THAT -- THE
IDEA THAT --
THERE THIS IS BEEN AN OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR THE LAST
TEN YEARS.
HE IS -- HE
FRANKLY RIDICULOUS.
AND THIS IS THE REASON WHY WE'RE
HERE -- I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT --
IT WE I AM CERTAINLY OPEN.
THE EYES THE SENATOR INDICATED --
THAT I THINK THAT'S MY MODUS
OPERANDI IS TO WORK WITH PEOPLE
TO TRY.
TO YOU KNOW CRAFT.
BETTER SOLUTIONS TO DIFFICULT
PROBLEMS.
I I HAVEN'T HEARD ONE HERE TODAY
IN THIS HEARING YET THAT --
THAT MOVES ME BUT I'M OPEN TO
DISCUSSING THIS WITH THE THE
OPPONENTS OF IT MOVING FORWARD --
YEAH THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE MY
REQUEST PRIOR TO MOVING THE BILL
TODAY --
WITH THE AMENDMENTS IS.
IS JUST THAT COMMITMENT I THINK.
OPPONENTS HAVE AN INTERESTING
CONCEPT FOR AN AMENDMENT.
ABOUT USING THE THE ANNUAL
BUDGET AS THIS SORT OF DRIVING
DOCUMENT.
LIKE I SAID WATER COMMISSION
THERE MAY BE OTHER WAYS THERE
ALSO MAY BE --
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T JUST FEEL
ANNUALIZED WHERE YOU CAN MAYBE
STILL USING THAT BUDGET DOCUMENT
AS POSE THIS --
CONCEDED THE ARBITRARY THRESHOLD
WE PUT IN HERE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS --
DOES HAVE SOMETHING A LITTLE
MORE CONSISTENT AT THEIRMAJOR
CHANGE IN THE PROJECT --
SUBSTANTIAL CHANGES THINGS THAT
REQUIRE JUST THE DRAFT IN THE
ANNUAL SO AS LONG AS YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH A LOOK AT THAT
AND WORK.
VERY HARD WITH THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER JUST
VERY AYE.
THANK YOU COULD I DO AGREE THAT
YOU ARE --
FABULESSLY GOOD TO WORK WITHALL
THE FRONTS I JUST THINK THAT.
PART OF THE ISSUE OF TRUST AND
PART OF THE ISSUE.
OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEKING TO
ACHIEVE HAS FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED BY THE AMENDMENTS YOU'VE
TAKEN.
THE BILL IS ORIGINALLY.
WRITTEN BEFORE THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS BY THE COMMITTEE WERE
ONE THERE WAS NO CAP ON MONEY
FIVE MILLION TO THAT IN THIS
PARAGRAPH THAT WAS TAKEN OUT THE
JOINT BUDGET COMMITTEE.
HAS NINETY DAYS TO REVIEW ALL
THE STUFF FOR EVERY SINGLE
CONTRACT IN A CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT AS WELL OVER THOUSAND
CONTRACTS WILL GO TO THIS
COMMITTEE THEY WILL ALL BE
REVIEWED WHATEVER IT IS.
AND THEN ONCE THE REVIEWED IN
THE GIVES IS THE WINDOW FOR THE
SLOW DOWN.
THE ONLY ARGUMENT MAKES YOU IS
THAT WELL OF COSTS GO UP THERE'S
ACTUALLY SOME --
REVERSION IN TERMS OF COSTS TO
RATEPAYERS ARGUABLY BUT PRETTY
THIN.
MY POINT IS THAT NOW YOU'VE
TAKEN THESE AMENDMENTS.
IF YOU THINK THROUGH EUROPE
OBJECTIVE OF TRANSPARENCY I
WOULD JUST SUGGEST AND
SUGGESTIONS IF WE PASS THIS
BECAUSE I CERTAINLY.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE I'M SITTING
HERE AND I APOLOGIZE AND GET THE
AS SOON --
TRYING TO CATCH UP WITH THE EVER
VOTE AGAINST THE DOT BILL
BECAUSE THEY VOTE AGAINST FAMILY
BUT TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE THAT WE'LL WE'LL MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS. THREE THOUGHT
THROUGH CONSISTENT WITH THE I
THINK IT'S REALLY HAS CHANGED.
OF FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT YOUR
ORIGINAL.
INITIATIVE WAS WITH RESPECT TO
THE CONTENTS OF THE MEASURE.
YOU KNOW IT'S A WHETHER IT'S A
BUDGET PROCESS OR SOMETHING ELSE
BUT THE NOTION IS TRANSPARENCY
WITHOUT DELAY I THINK THAT'S THE
MESSAGE THAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
SEND YEAR.
TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT DELAY AND
CREATING THIS THE AND CLEARLY
THIS HAD A 100% ROAD BLOCK UNTIL
IT WAS TAKEN OUT BY THE
COMMITTEE.
AND THE STILL ARGUABLY SOME ROAD
BLOCKS AND THE IDEA IS
TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT DELAY IS
THAT A FAIR STATEMENT
[inaudible]
CHAIR MERECE --
SO WITH WITH YOUR COMMITMENT.
AND THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE
AMENDMENTS I THINK.
LONG AND WE'RE GONNA JUST KEEP
WORKING ON THIS.
I THINK WE CAN MOVE THIS TODAY --
I YEAH I I DO APPRECIATE CENTER
HERTZBERG.
COMMENTING CONCERNS I ALSO WOULD
ENCOURAGE A STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY.
TO THE THE NATURE THIS HEARING
YOU KNOW.
WE'VE GOT A TRUNCATED PERIOD OF
REVIEW IN GENERAL.
AT OPPOSITION COME LATE WE'VE
HAD SUPPORT WITH.
THIS SPEAKING AMENDMENTS COME
LATE SO HOPEFULLY GOING FOR WE
HAVE WE CAN BAKE SOME OF THIS
MORE FULLY BUT I DO APPRECIATE
JUST.
ADD YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS SO
FAR AND I'M PREPARED TO TO SEE
ARE YOU STILL MOVING TOWARD HIM
AND YELP THE SAN DIEGO TO
MEMBERS WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
I'M NO.
NO [inaudible]
COMMITTEES.
AND I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE YOU
TO UTILIZE THE FONT OF KNOWLEDGE
WE HAVE HERE ON SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES IN WATER THANK YOU AND
AND I'D LIKE TO ALSO SAY I WILL
SUPPORT THIS GOING FOR BUT I DO
HAVE A LOT OF RESERVATIONS AND
AND I KNOW THAT YOU WILL.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS AND SO
ARE YOU.
WILL LAW LIKE I THINK MANY OF US
BE WATCHING THIS VERY CAREFULLY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTERS WE DO HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR HERTZBERG
THAT ESY TO PASS WITH
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THIS CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
STERN AYE STERN I'D JONES ALLEN.
BUSH'S CARRERO HERTZBERG HERS
FOR A GUY HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONEY.
I AM AS AMENDED IN WITH THE
COMMITMENTS OF THE AUTHOR THANK
VERY GOOD.
MONEY IN AYE THE BILL HAS
SUFFICIENT BOTH LOCAL OKAY SO WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL THOUGH
THAT BILL DOES HAVE SUFFICIENT
VOTES --
THANK YOU CENTER DOT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT --
SO WE ARE GOING TO LIFT THE
COALS -- ON
THE OUTSTANDING MEASURES HE I'VE.
I THINK WE'VE GOT [inaudible]
GOT SOME.
OKAY WELL LET'S LET'S JUST ROLL
THROUGH REAL QUICK --
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE SB EIGHT
GLAZER THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE CURRENT BONUS FOUR TO
ONE SENATORS BURGESS HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON HI.
THE HAS IN THE FIRST WE SHOULD
LEAVE A MARGIN OKAY WE WE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
OUTSTANDING MEMBER ITEM NUMBER
TWO SB.
NINETEEN SENATOR DODD DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS VOTERS FIVE
ZERO SENATORS JONES BURGESS
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN
TWO ZERO WE WILL KEEP THAT ON
CALL THOUGH --
THE ITEM NUMBER THREE SB SIXTY
TWO DODD DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTERS
FIVE ZERO SENATORS JONES FORGES
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I'D JACKSON.
JACKSON HI AGAIN THAT HAS --
THE DECISION VOTES BUT WE WILL
KEEP THAT ON CALL AS WELL AND
FINALLY KNOW.
WHERE WE'RE AT ITEM FOR SO?
WAITING FOR ME ARE GOING TO HANG
OUT.
AND HAVE FUN [inaudible]
IN WATER.
NO JUST WANTS TO WATCH ME SIT
HERE.
I'M A LITTLE OFFENDED IT'S MY
FIRST HEARING.
THANK YOU TINA [inaudible]
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
AWESOME
YOU TO READ THROUGH THE
FOR THE HONOR CIVIL WAR YEAH
YEAH IS THAT RIGHT OKAY SO --
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA LET THE CALL.
FOR THEM ONE SB EIGHT THAT IS
GLAZER TO PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS
CONVERT A SEVEN TO ONE SENATOR
BURGESS.
I JUST KNOW.
THAT OUT SEVENTY TWO BILLS THAT --
SEVENTY TWO FILE AND TO SEE SB
NINETEEN DODD TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS VOTER SEVEN ZERO
CENTERS JONES BURGESS.
BURGESS I WAS EIGHT ZERO IS OUT
OKAY -- FILE
ITEM OF THAT THE BILL IS OUT --
FILING THREE SB SIXTY TWO THAT
IS DODD DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT LOTUS
SEVEN ZERO CENTERS JONES BURGESS.
FOR JUST BY A BILLS OUT EIGHT
ZERO OKAY.
WITH THAT BILL IS OUT IN OUR
FINAL ITEM A NUMBER FOR SB TOOL
FOR THAT BILL IS OUT WITH A DO
PASS AS AMENDED.
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE ZERO CENTERS
JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BARGES [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
THE BILL IS NOW IS SIX ZERO AND
WE'RE WAITING FOR CABALLERO BUT
WE CAN CLOSE ON CALL.
I THINK SHE'S I THINK SHE'S
STUCK IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
SO.
I WAS JUST TECH.
SURE -- WE
WILL PUT A CALL FOR ONE SECOND
.
ANNOUNCED THAT SO WE ARE.
NUMBER FOUR OUT OF SIX ZERO WE
ARE GOING TO CLOSE THE RULES A
AND NUMBER I NEVER FORCED ME TO
AFFORD IS OUT --
SIX ZERO AND WITH THAT WE ARE
ADJOURNED